Genau gesagt, mit dem Chaos-Radio wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat hier bei Fritz. Drei Stunden rund um das Thema Computer im weitesten Sinne. Mit dem Chaos-Computer Club und mit Johnny. Jetzt gibt es wie üblich im Chaos Radio den anfänglichen Chaos Soundcheck sozusagen. Können wir mal alle Hallo sagen?
Können wir das mitbekommen?
Das ist super schwierig einzustellen, aber so geht's, ne?
Naja, Test, ja, Test.
1, 2, 1, 2.
Ich finde das klingt großartig. Herzlich willkommen beim Chaos Radio mit vier Chaoten heute hier im Studio und zwar ganz besonderen. Andi, willst du nicht mal die Runde vorstellen vielleicht?
Ja, also das Konzept der Sendung ist sozusagen ein ganz anderes. Wir haben hier jetzt mal drei Vertreter aus dem Urschleim des Clubs sozusagen geladen von der wahrlich ersten Generation zur ganz linken, aber das wird ihr Hörer ja nicht, ist der Peter Glaser? Der vielleicht auch nochmal zwei Worte zu sich selbst sagen mag oder drei?
Gern, ja. Ich bin Outdoor, ein Freund des Chaos Computer Clubs. Seit langer, langer Zeit war man eine Zeit lang Chefredakteur der Datenschleuder. Ja, das Wichtigste in Kürze.
Outdoor ist so untertrieben, finde ich. Du hast eine ganze Menge Bücher geschrieben zur großen, weiten Welt, der Daten, der Kommunikation vor allen Dingen. Du setzt dich damit als einer der wenigen Journalisten eigentlich schon sehr lange auseinander in Deutschland, ne?
Ja, das stimmt. Also ich hatte immer Schwierigkeiten. Ich bin eher Schriftsteller als Journalist. Ich schreib sehr viel für Zeitungen und es gab Zeiten, zu denen es mir sehr schwer gemacht worden ist oder ich es mir selber sehr schwer gemacht habe, als Schriftsteller zu sein. Die erste Zeit war Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre, als Punk und die nahe Deutsche Welle kamen, weil damals war es fast ausweglos, nicht Popstar werden zu wollen. Ich saß mit meiner Schreibmaschine, ich hab in einem Studio gewohnt praktisch im Keller in Düsseldorf und hatte meine Schreibmaschine im Nebenzimmer und da kamen dann Leute rein, gucken die Schreibmaschine an, wie wenn jemand so einen Ammoniten oder irgendeine Versteinerung an den Tisch liegen ging. Und das hat mir Selbstbewusstsein gebracht. Und das zweite war der Computer, an dem ich sehr großen Spaß gefunden hab, weil ich jetzt endlich als Schriftsteller auch eine schöne Maschine wie die Musiker hatte, mit der man Lärm machen konnte, was mein Selbstbewusstsein etwas gesteigert hat. Und da ging wieder das Problem los, wie kann ich verhindern Programmierer zu werden oder Techniker zu werden und Schriftsteller zu bleiben. Und an diesen Kämpfen und Gefechten habe ich mich immer irgendwie hochgezogen.
Na gut, und dann etwas daneben? Nein, mehr in der Mitte sozusagen. Räumlich angeordnet ist der WIC. Tja, vielleicht...
Na ja, ich würde sagen, ich bin das krasse Gegenteil von Peter Glaser. Ich habe mich im Club, oder als der Club so aufkam, in dem Triumphirat immer im Wesentlichen um die Technik gekümmert, weil eigentlich die anderen Beteiligten eher weniger mit Technik zu tun hatten. Und ich doch tatsächlich einer der wenigen gewesen bin, der eine gewisse Begeisterung für die Technik aufgebracht hat und die auch tatsächlich versucht hat, in allen ihren technischen, sozialen und sonstigen Auswirkungen auch zu analysieren und zu verstehen. Und so ist es dann auch gekommen, dass ich dann irgendwann auch beruflich Elektronik-Sachverständiger geworden bin.
Und dann haben wir hier noch den Vau, der sich auch lieber selbst vorstellt, glaube ich, weil da kann ich sowieso noch Falsches sagen.
Naja, ich habe mich mit Computern schon etliche Jahre beschäftigt, eben bevor es einen Chaos Computer Club gab. Und letztes Wochenende war ich in Kiel und habe in der gleichen Kneipe gehabt, wo wir vor 20 Jahren die ersten Treffen mit Computerfreaks hatten. Also so 1979, die ersten CPM-Treffen damals. Und die Kneipe sieht noch genauso aus wie damals. Es hängt nur ein Linux-Installationsplakat im Eingang. Und irgendwann sind aus diesen bundesdeutschen Treffen der CCC entstanden.
Tja, und dann sitzt da noch Andi, der euch gerade die anderen vorgestellt hat. Den kennt ihr, der war schon oft hier.
Und ein Wort würde ich vielleicht noch zum Konzept der Sendung sagen.
Ich dachte du wolltest auch noch was zu dir selber sagen.
Ach, ich selber halt.
Was ich entscheiden finde, ist, wir wollen euch jetzt nicht damit langweilen, wie war das damals vor 20 Jahren, als wir irgendwie noch CPM ohne Feiersystem oder mit? Aber das war eigentlich nicht das ursprüngliche Konzept. Das ursprüngliche Konzept und das Thema lautet ein bisschen Vision und Netzwerke, oder sagen wir mal auch ein bisschen Vision und Realitäten vielleicht, weil es gab damals ja einige, sagen wir mal, mehr oder weniger naive Gedanken, was man mit Computern und Vernetzung so anstellen könnte, die auch zur Gründung des CCC geführt haben. Und es gibt heute etwas, das heißt Internet, und das ist so ein bisschen ja das, was daraus geworden ist. Und für mich stellte sich auch die Frage, ich habe es jetzt sozusagen geschafft, hier mal ein paar Leute in einen Raum zu bringen, die relativ lange nicht mehr so in der auch aus räumlichen Gründen in einem Raum saßen und diese Diskussion geführt haben. Früher haben sie das häufiger gemacht, so vor zehn Jahren. Was daraus eigentlich geworden ist, inwieweit das überhaupt mit ihren Vorstellungen übereinstimmt und wie das dann eigentlich weitergeht. Und ja, Vic hatte vorhin schon irgendwie die kurze Eingebung, irgendwie wir können da sowieso nicht mehr viel viel falsches erzählen, weil das ist sowieso schon in den Brunnen gefallen.
Das klingt so ein bisschen, aber nein.
Ich meine eigentlich, wir können alles sagen, weil die eventuell heutzutage daraus resultierenden Straftaten längst verjährt sind.
Da sind wir jetzt natürlich schon mitten drin in diesem Thema, was Andi gerade umrissen hat, nämlich so grob gesagt, ist das, was wir heute haben, eigentlich das, was ihr damals wolltet oder was ihr euch vorgestellt habt, eine Art Chaos Radio, Chaos Computer Club Veteranentreffen sozusagen.
Naja, nicht nur, aber auch was führt denn daraus? Also auch schon die Frage nach den Visionen und da sind natürlich auch die Hörer gefragt, inwieweit die denn mit irgendwelchen Vorstellungen mal sich dem Medium Computer genähert haben und die jetzt vielleicht mal ein paar Jahre später feststellen, ob denn das, was daraus geworden ist in ihrem persönlichen Nutzen oder auch in dem, was man da so anderenorts feststellt, mit dem in irgendeiner Form in positiver Übereinstimmung oder in welcher Form auch immer korrespondiert.
Ihr könnt uns die nächsten, na jetzt sind es nicht mehr drei Stunden, aber zwei Stunden, zweihundert, dreiviertel Stunde. Bis ein Uhr werdet ihr einen interessanten Abend hier vor euch haben. Ihr könnt uns im Radio hören natürlich. Ihr könnt uns auch erstmalig beim Chaos Radio direkt live im Netz hören, über Real Audio nämlich. Ihr geht einfach auf die Fritz-Seiten unter www.fritz.de. Da gibt es einen direkten Link dahin. Wer einen Real Audio Player installiert hat, der kann uns dort hören. Was natürlich ein bisschen Quatsch ist, wenn ihr uns jetzt im Radio hört. Aber vielleicht könnt ihr euren Freunden und Freundinnen Bescheid sagen, die nicht in unserem Sendegebiet sitzen, dass auch die sich heute Abend beteiligen können. Und im Chat geht es natürlich auch wie immer los, nämlich unter www.fritz.de. Ist der TeleNet-Chat auf Ihnen?
Nee, ich glaube, die sind alle im Kino wegen dieser 23.
Wegen 23, genau. Aber dann treffen wir uns halt unter dem Fritz Studio Chat. Und ja, ihr könnt euch auch demnächst einschalten. Und wir werden dann gleich richtig eintauchen in dieses sicher, unterhaltsam und interessante Thema. Chaosradio Musik heute vom Analog Club DJ Team. Die könnt ihr übrigens demnächst dann auch live mal genießen. Zum Beispiel am Freitag ab 10 Uhr im NDI in der Schönhause Allee 8 oder kommenden Montag ebenfalls ab 10, abends natürlich, mit Mixed Master Morris zusammen im Ex-Postamt Straße der Pariser Kommune 8, 9, 10 und am Samstag, den 12. September mit dem Synapsen Team Hamburg ebenfalls im Ex-Postamt Straße der Pariser Kommune. Dann sag ich aber nachher alles nochmal durch. Bevor wir loslegen, würde ich gerne von einer Person hören, die jetzt vielleicht uns auf Real Audio hört, vom Computer sitzt. Vielleicht einen kurzen Kontrollanruf mal, ob das alles draußen bei euch gut ankommt über den Rechner. Ansonsten würde ich nämlich mit Schrammkontakt nehmen. Gucken wir nochmal, ob man da was nachregeln muss. Falls also jemand jetzt uns über Real Audio hören kann, kurzer Anruf unter 0331 70 97 110 wäre nett. Und dann können wir das über Telefon auch kontrollieren und haben dann ein schönes Feedback. Gucken wir, wie das klingt. Problematik wird wahrscheinlich sein, dass wir jemanden brauchen, der Radio hört, im Internet ist und jetzt auch noch eine Telefonleitung frei hat. Hallo? Hallo Mario. Ja, hast du den? Problematik wird wahrscheinlich sein, dass wir jemanden brauchen, der Radio hört, im Internet ist und jetzt auch noch eine Telefonleitung frei hat. Hallo Mario.
Ja, hast du den?
Super, das können wir jetzt stundenlang wiederholen.
Großartig.
Mario, bist du dran? Also bei dir kommt es gut an? Klasse. Zwar mit einer Verzögerung von etwa bestimmt fünf bis zehn Sekunden, aber egal, das soll uns wurscht sein. Mario, ich dank dir. Chaos Radio bei Fritz und ihr habt gehört, dass wir einige Leute hier haben. Ihr seht euch nicht so oft wirklich, ne?
Relativ selten. Das bringt das Erwachsenen geworden sein, ein bisschen so nach sich. Ja, naja, jeder von uns ist in der Zwischenzeit abgeklebt in einem Beruf.
Ja, aber Computer jetzt übertreibt es auch ein bisschen. Also das war 10, 15 Jahre älter als ich oder irgendwas, aber als Berufskind hast du doch eigentlich dir das gerade noch verkniffen, jetzt irgendwie hier Schlips und Kragen anzuziehen.
Berufskind ist ja fast eine Beleidigung für mich. Was?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das stimmt schon. Also Berufsjugendlicher wären eine Beleidigung. Genau, es geht uns doch allen so, dass wir irgendwann mal ungestört spielen konnten, und dann kommt einem die Pubertät dazwischen, dann hört das alles auf und irgendwie muss man sich hinterher bemühen, wieder in Ruhe sozusagen fertig spielen zu können.
Warum wollen das Männer mehr als Frauen?
Das muss man die Frauen fragen.
Schauen wir mal, das kann ja die Frage an die Hörerinnen sagen.
Na, man kann also zum Beispiel, da ist das Computerthema schon ganz geeignet. Der Computer ist ein, ich hab manchmal die Vermutung, dass immer noch niemand weiß, was man mit Computern eigentlich machen soll, dass es aber zu spät ist, überhaupt eine Antwort darauf zu geben. Weil es sozusagen schon die Weltwirtschaft okkupiert hat, das ganze Thema. Und das Computer im Grunde genommen nur dazu da ist, diesen Spieltrieb umzusetzen. Und das Schöne am Computer ist, man braucht nur ein ernstes Gesicht zu machen. Also früher, so in den Frühzeiten, gab es immer Spiele mit so einer Panik-Taste oder mit so einem P-Knopf. Da konnte man dann draufdrücken und dann hatte man plötzlich eine Tabellenkalkulation irgendwie am Bildschirm, wenn irgendwie ein Vorgesetzter oder sonst jemand vorbeiging. Oder bei mir zu Hause, zum Beispiel, waren mal zu einer Zeit, als Computer zu Hause noch nicht so üblich, waren Mormonen. Da kamen zwei Mormonen rein und brachten, wollten wir das heilbringen. Und dann sahen die, dass ich da vorm Computer saß und das war für die einfach eine Bürosituation. Und dann sagten die sofort, oh, das tut uns leid und gingen raus. Und du hast gerade Kampen gespielt. Genau. Und dann habe ich plötzlich gemerkt, es ist so diese Aura der Ernsthaftigkeit und das nutzen in der Zwischenzeit alle schamlos aus. Es wird, glaube ich, überhaupt nur das, was Arbeit heißt, es wird immer mehr spielen.
Das ist relativ deckungsgleich mit dem, was Kollege von dir, nämlich William Gibson, über das WWW gesagt hat. Der meinte auch, in der schnellen und stressigen Zeit, die wir alle haben, sind die Computer und speziell das World Wide Web einfach dringend notwendig dafür, dass man wieder mal richtig schön sich die Zeit sinnlos vertreiben kann.
Das ist ein riesiges Abenteuerspiel. Das ist was ganz Wunderbares.
Aber wo du das gerade erwähnt hast, Peter, und wo Vic auch gerade neben dir sitzt, weil das habe ich nämlich auch nicht so oft, wer von euch beiden ist eigentlich dafür verantwortlich, dass dein C64 anstelle eines Reset-Tasters einen Knopf mit dem Namen Vergeltung trägt? Ich weiß, dass Vic ihn eingebaut hat, aber wer war eigentlich für die Beschriftung?
Für die Beschriftung war Vic zuständig, für die Ursache war ich zuständig. Und zwar hat Vic mir freundlicherweise, glaube ich, überhaupt einen Reset-Taster angebracht. Der war nämlich damals nicht üblich. Und dann habe ich irgendwann mal in so einem komatösen Moment mich auf meinen Rechner gelümmelt mit dem Arm. Und dann Vic angerufen und gesagt, mein Rechner steht, es funktioniert überhaupt nichts mehr und so weiter. Und festgestellt, dass ich irgendwie auf dem Reset-Taster gelümmelt habe. Und Vic hat mir dann irgendwie so einen gesicherten oder so einen Reset-Taster mit einer Art Überrollbügel oder irgend so was gebaut. Und bei der Gelegenheit dann gleich nochmal, weil ich ja eher ein textorientierter Mensch bin, dann Vergeltungen mit so einer Klebetextfolie drunter geschrieben.
Ja, also zudem, ich glaube, dass das Frauenthema sollte man unbedingt nochmal aufgreifen. Ich habe nämlich also jetzt rein vom Erleben her, die Anfangszeit der Computer, da waren diese Computer absolut, sage ich mal, die hatten keine Gefühlseite. Die waren also, die waren eckig gebaut. Die hatten klappernde, laute Tastaturen, sahen hässlich aus. Naja, wir wollen jetzt hier keine Werbung machen. Also das Konzept diskutieren wir woanders. Ich meine nur, dass eben ich zum Beispiel sofort eine Affinität zu diesen komischen, hölzernen Kästen gekriegt habe, weil ich vom Prinzip her praktisch mit der Logik geboren wurde. Das heißt also...
Aber Leute würden vielleicht sagen, in deiner Kindheit muss irgendwas schiefgelaufen sein.
Ja genau, so kann man es auch nennen. Aber ich glaube, dass dieser Werdegang gar nicht so untypisch ist für Männer.
Vielleicht liegt das auch an den erziehenden Frauen.
Vielleicht sind Männer überhaupt diejenigen, bei denen in der Kindheit irgendwas schiefgegangen ist.
Na ja, da können ja eigentlich nur die Frauen dann schuld sein. Aber es ist ja egal. Wir wollen ja hier auch keinen Geschlechterhass verbreiten. Ich meine nur, dass es eben einfach in meiner Zeit, wo ich groß geworden bin, eine Tatsache war, dass wir eben, ob es nun gedrillt war, ich glaube aber es steckt auch irgendwie schon in mir drin, weil meine Tochter ist genauso, dass wir einfach so eine hohe Affinität zur Logik gehabt haben und dadurch im Grunde genommen den Anschluss an die Maschine, also die Maschine hat im Grunde genommen, egal wie sie aussah, das richtige Interface gehabt für mich, die richtige Schnittstelle. Das hat sofort funktioniert, die Kommunikation. Und das glaube ich, ist von jemandem, der etwas sage ich mal vom formlichen oder gefühlsmäßigen angeht, überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Ist das denn bei dir jetzt mal historisch gefasst, weil ich kenne dich ja auch erst, da war ich noch relativ klein, aber du warst schon etwas länger mit Computern betraut. Stand dieses Zurechtkommen mit der Maschine denn bei dir in einem Missverhältnis mit dem Zurechtkommen mit anderen Sachen? Also ich meine, wir haben ja in Berlin so ein, zwei Freaks, die können beispielsweise Chipkarten, also in einer Art und Weise, im Detail Bit für Bit analysieren. Also da kommen auch ich nicht mehr mit, da kommen auch viele bei uns nicht mehr mit. Auf der anderen Seite sind das aber auch Kandidaten, die, sagen wir mal, mit dem Interface Mensch, also mit dem Zurechtkommen mit anderen Menschen, weitaus mehr Probleme haben, als mit einer Chipkarte zu reden. Also hast du da auch irgendwie historisch gesehen mal so ein Missverhältnis gehabt, oder würdest du das irgendwie da nicht so sehen?
Doch, auf jeden Fall. Das trifft zu, würde ich sagen. Nun ist natürlich die Frage, was ist die Ursache und was ist die Wirkung? Das ist letztlich die Frage nach der Henne oder dem Ei. Denn wenn man sich jetzt sehr intensiv damit beschäftigt und ich sage mal, sehr tiefgründige logische Gedanken verfolgen möchte, dann wird es automatisch um einen herum dunkel, weil man sonst gar nicht unten ankommt. Nun kann man natürlich auch sagen, man beschäftigt sich nur deswegen damit, weil es sowieso um einen herum dunkel ist. Ich kann also jetzt die Frage, ob das eine aus dem anderen folgt oder andersrum nicht beantworten. Aber sicherlich ist es dazu auch gekommen.
Da muss ich aber Wick ein bisschen vor sich selber in Schutz nehmen. Ich würde einfach sagen, dass Wick jemand ist, der wie ein Schachspieler denkt. Sehr konsequent, sehr weit voraus und für viele andere Leute sehr anstrengend und konsequent. Und die Konsequenz liegt zum Beispiel darin, dass Wick sich immer sehr, so habe ich ihn auch kennengelernt, und so eingehend mit der Technik beschäftigt, dass zum Beispiel so etwas wie Gehäuse sind für Wick immer eine Frage gewesen, die irrelevant war. Ich habe von Wick mein allererster Modem bekommen, eins der berühmten Chaos Daten Clubs, die Bau Nr. 4. Das war ein Werradrad-Verhau, aus dem oben zwei rote Jumbo-Lights rausgucken, das sah aus wie so eine Garnel, wie eine Außerirdische. Und das stand dann bei mir am Schreibtisch und ich bin einer von den anderen Leuten, die gerne ein Gehäuse hätten. Und ich hab wirklich irgendwann mal gebeten, aber es ist vollkommen unverständlich, dass man Gehäuse haben will, weil wirklich irgendwie den unmittelbaren Zugang, die Veränderungsmöglichkeiten, die Eingriffsmöglichkeiten in die Technik, da kann man ja noch was dran verbessern und so weiter und so fort. Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, da liegt irgendwie ein Freund mit geöffneter Bauchdecke vor mir, und ich schreib sie und hab wirklich gebeten, ob er da nicht Abhilfe schaffen kann, was er dann freundlicherweise auch gemacht hat. Es war dann so ein, damals ist der Bildschirmtext gerade aufgekommen, so ein BTX-Decoder-Gehäuse, in das das Ganze dann hineingetarnt worden ist. Weil das war ja damals alles verboten und illegal, ne? Also vielleicht noch ein Anschluss zu dieser Eingangsbemerkung von Wegen, alles was wir heute sagen kann nicht mehr strafrechtlich relevant verwertet werden. Es war definitiv alles, was wir heute tun, mit der allergrößten Selbstverständlichkeit verboten, als wir angefangen haben.
Wir bringen gleich mal ein bisschen Licht überhaupt in diese, ja nicht allzu ferne Vergangenheit und erzählen mal so ein bisschen von früher. Wir wollen das natürlich nicht zu so einer Sendung werden lassen, wo alles nur, ah, früher war und so weiter. Das kennen wir jetzt so genüge. Das haben wir musikalisch, gerade haben wir 80er-Jahre-Wochen bei Fritz gerade irgendwie und das ist enorm erfolgreich. Leute wollen alle die 80er Jahre Musik hören. Heute gibt es ein bisschen 80er Jahre Computerteam. Dann ansatzweise, das machen wir gleich nach dem Fritz Kurz-Inpo, was gleich folgt und dann können wir vielleicht auch mal danach dann schon mal die Telefone eröffnen. Vielleicht kann man die Frage mit, ob Jungs da mehr den Spieltrieb weiter verfolgen oder so. Vielleicht kann man die nachher auch mal in die Hörer und vor allen Dingen Hörerinnen weitergeben. Musik im Chaosradio heute vom Analog Club DJ Team. Mal gucken, ob ich es noch mal schaffe, ohne mich dabei zu versprechen. Die ihr, wie gesagt, in den nächsten Tagen auch live erleben könnt, das erzähl ich euch dann aber nachher nochmal.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 22.30 Uhr.
Kritik, die scheidende Ausländerbeauftragte des Bundes Schmalls Jakobsen hat der Politik Versäumnisse bei der Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus vorgeworfen. Angesichts gewalttätiger Übergriffe und einer wachsenden Zahl von Anhängern rechter Gruppen hätte sich der Bundestag intensiv mit diesem Thema beschäftigen müssen. Ausgangssperre. Sie wurde am Abend über Kongos Hauptstadt Kinshasa verhängt. Vorangegangen waren stundenlange Gefechte zwischen Regierungstruppen und Rebellen am Rande Kind Kinshasas. Die Rebellen erklärten, sie hätten Teile der Stadt unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht. Machtkampf. Angesichts der schweren Finanzkrise in Russland hat das Parlament in Moskau den Druck auf Präsident Yeltsin verstärkt. Eine Kommission legte ein Konzept für eine drastische Beschneidung seiner Verfassungsrechte vor. Yeltsin lehnte dies ab. Sturmwarnung. Aus Furcht vor dem Hurricane Bonnie sind eine halbe Million Menschen an der Ostküste der USA evakuiert worden. Meteorologen erwarten, dass der Sturm noch am Abend mit Geschwindigkeiten von 185 Kilometern pro Stunde auf die Küste trifft.
Fußball.
Bayern München hat als zweiter deutscher Club die Hauptrunde der Champions League erreicht. Nach dem 4 zu 0 Hinspielsieg schafften die Bayern im Rückspiel bei Obelitsch-Belgrad ein 1 zu 1 unentschieden.
Wetter.
Abends und nachts einzelne Schauer 10 bis 7 Grad, morgen dann wechselhaft Temperaturen bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr.
Stadtverkehr Berlin Spandau, Straße am Julius Turm Richtung Falkenseer Platz. In Höhe Breite Straße wird der Verkehr über die Gegenfahrbahn geleitet. Es kommt zum Stau.
Das war ein Fritz Kurzinformat, Gerhard Kötterheimrich.
Fritz präsentiert die Wobbentour 98. Mit Bad Religion, 5 Sterne Deluxe, The Specials, Fitshifter, Lag Wagon und einem ziemlich unbekannten Punk Ensemble aus Düsseldorf. Außerdem Skate und BMX Profis aus Amerika. Die Wobbentour 98. Mittwoch, 9. September, ab 16 Uhr in der Freilichtbühne Wuhlheide.
Und gewobbt wird hier auch, nämlich zeitgeworbt sozusagen. Welcome back beim Chaos Radio. Jedes Mittwoch im Monat hier bei Fritz. Und heute Abend exklusiv für euch, tata, auch live im Netz per Real Audio. Ihr könnt unter www.fritz.de, da ist ein Button drauf, da klickt einfach drauf und dann könnt ihr das hören. Und es wäre nett, wenn die Leute, die im Chat sind oder im IRC oder Tenet Chat, funktioniert scheinbar doch, sagt hier gerade jemand. Also wenn ihr da allen möglichen Menschen Bescheid sagt, dass man es per Real Audio auch hören kann und nicht nur im Radio, hier im Sendegebiet. Ansonsten möchten wir natürlich auch alle Leute dran behalten, die nicht vernetzt sind, zumindest nicht per Internet. Man ist ja auch anders vernetzt, Telefone sind ja auch eine Art Netzwerk. Von Chaos Radio heute bei Peter Glaser, Vic, Vau und Andi. Die Musik, ich sag's noch mal, vom Analog Club DJ Team. Jetzt hat er es geschafft. Und kurz vor dem Fritz Kurzendwo haben wir so ein bisschen angefangen, in die Vergangenheit zu reisen. Das können wir vielleicht auch mal machen. Kleinen Ausflug für alle die, die jetzt vielleicht 14 sind, gerade ihren T-Online-Anschluss auf die Reihe gekriegt haben, auf ihrem PC nach nur zwei Wochen. Na, kleiner Seitenhieb. Na, fandet ihr nicht lustig.
Schade.
Er die kleinen Unterschiede.
Manchmal seid ihr ein bisschen ernst.
Ja, wir haben gerade...
Peter!
Aufwarnen. Wir waren gerade... Ich fand das auch spannend als Bestandsaufnahme sozusagen, weil ich hab neulich mal mein Zeitungsarchiv aufgeräumt, so 80er-Jahre technisch und so und diese Schlagzeilen, die damals so NASA hackt oder so was verursacht haben, abgesehen von dem, was wir uns an Ärger aufgehalzt haben, stand eigentlich in gar keinem Verhältnis zu dem, was da de facto passiert ist, weil heute nennt man das Internet-Surfen und ist im Grunde genommen nichts anderes, nur dass man heute dazu keinen 202A mehr gibt, begehen muss, oder keinen Computerbetrug mehr und auch man wird nicht mal mehr so leicht statisch geprüfter Hacker, wir sagen, mit Hausdurchsuchung versehen oder so, sondern heute geht man in den Laden, sagt eine Packung Internet, dann trägt man die nach Hause, kriegt die an, dann kann man einen WWW-Nahsag aufmachen und gut ist.
Auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise ist das ja eine Antwort auf die Frage, was ist aus dem geworden, was wir uns damals vorgestellt haben. Was wir uns damals vorgestellt haben, war auf einer Seite auch ganz einfach, wir wollen, dass alles irgendwie schneller und billiger läuft. Als es die ersten Mailboxen gab, war das eine große Sensation. Dann hatten wir uns natürlich gewünscht, dass sich die verbinden miteinander und dass sich dann kleine Netze bildeten und dass sich diese Netze mit anderen Netzen wiederum verbinden und da gab es dann Ungeheuer. Ich erinnere mich noch lange Listen, wie man irgendwie, es war furchtbar kompliziert von einem Netz ins andere in den Mail schicken, das war eine Geheimwissenschaft.
Aber die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist, ob ihr damals eigentlich schon eine Ahnung hatte von der Inflation der Informationen, weil ich weiß noch, der Chaos Communication Congress 86 oder 87, das war kurz nach der Veröffentlichung dieses NASA-Hacks und der Bullenaktion, die wir hatten und so weiter und fort, da saß Vic irgendwie mit einem riesigen Papierstapel in einem Raum mit ungefähr 150 Journalisten, obwohl da eigentlich nur 30 Leute bequem Platz gefunden hätten und hat also dann irgendwie aus den NASA-Logfiles irgendwie vorgelesen. Das lustigste war glaube ich noch dieser Bericht über die Rakete, diese Testraketen, die sie da hatten, die ihn dann quer durch die Werkshalle gefahren ist und im gegenüberliegenden Gebäude irgendwie stecken, ob die müssen irgendwas und also das war das Einzelste, wo wir uns so königlich darüber amüsieren konnten. Wir hatten mal ein Stück lustiges Information bei der NASA gefunden irgendwie. Aber ansonsten, wenn man das irgendwie aus heutiger Sicht beurteilt, war das doch relativ mittelrelevantes Zeug, oder?
Ja, aber diese Informationsüberflutung, da hat Vau für mich einen Schlüsselsatz dazu gesagt, nämlich es geht uns zwar schon ziemlich früh, Mitte der 80er Jahre, als er mal sagte, es geht eigentlich nicht mehr darum, um die Frage, wenn man den Weg des Datenschutzes nimmt, wie schütze ich meine Informationen vorm Zugriff irgendeines Geheimdienst, sondern es geht eher um die Frage, wie schütze ich mich vor Informationen. Und als damals die Volkszählung lief, haben wir ja auch versucht, das umzusetzen in eine Strategie, wo wir gesagt haben, wir wollen jetzt nicht mehr, wie das so die ganzen 70er-Jahre hindurch gemacht worden ist, so diese klassische Proteststrategie durchziehen und sagen, du kriegst gar keine Daten von uns, du böser Staat und so weiter, sondern dass man das dann umkehrt und sagt, man macht so diese Informationsüberflutung zu einer Strategie und sagt, ok, ich unterstütze die Volkszählung, ich finde die Volkszählung richtig toll und zwar geht es so, ich schreibe in den Fragebogen überall rein, siehe Anlage, siehe Anlage, siehe Anlage, dann erstmal handgeschriebener Lebenslauf, wie man es beigebracht bekommen hat und dann alles richtig so, wann ich mein erstes Fahrrad bekommen habe und so weiter und so fort, weil ich die Volkszählung richtig gut finde und weil ich wichtig finde, dass der Staat irgendwie Zugriff auf diese Informationen hat und in der Hoffnung, dass das alles dann besser wird. Und wenn das nur ein Promille der Leute gemacht hätten damals, dann hätten die Silos bauen müssen, allein um irgendwie die ganzen Bögen mit den Anlagen umzusetzen.
Aber das hat einen Denkfehler, denn in der Geschichte der menschlichen Entwicklung haben wir jetzt den Punkt erreicht, wo die Speichermöglichkeiten rapide schneller wachsen als das menschliche Wissen. Und auf einer Datenschutzkonferenz letzte Woche hat ein Niederländer eine Zahl genannt, nämlich 2008, Ende der Privatheit, zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist über uns alle so viel gespeichert, dass man eigentlich alles über jeden wissen kann.
Ja gut, und wer soll das alles noch lesen?
Also heute gibt es Suchmaschinen und dann gibt es eben Menschenprofilmaschinen. Das ist genauso machbar, da lassen sich auch Psychogramme maschinell auswerten und da lässt sich eine ganze Menge standardisieren.
Gibt es natürlich jetzt irgendwie, zweimal ist mir aufgefallen, dass wir natürlich auch darüber reden müssen, welche Informationen der Einzelne, ob jetzt als Individuum oder als Firma oder als Institution überhaupt zulässt und das hat sich doch überhaupt nicht geändert. Wenn du sagst, damals irgendwie NASA-Verbindung war Pressekonferenzen wert und ein riesen Ding und heute kann jeder WWW-NASA-Org machen, kann er zwar, aber im Grunde genommen sind wir natürlich trotzdem wieder an dem Punkt, wie vorher, bevor man an diesen NASA-Server rangekommen ist, denn wir kriegen jetzt weiterhin nur das, was die NASA uns wissen lassen will. Und da ist doch der Unterschied, oder, dass ihr damals eine Verbindung zu einem Server hattet, zu dem eigentlich keiner eine haben sollte, an ganz andere Informationen kommen konntet eventuell.
War aber nicht der Fall.
Naja, es war in gewisser Weise schon der Fall und sei es auch nur, dass die NASA möglicherweise verbergen wollte, dass sie sich generell nur mit mittelrelevanten Zeugzeugen, wenn ich das mal zitieren darf, gefassen. Und die werden ja von Steuergeldern finanziert und insofern denke ich mir mal, hätten die sicherlich auch ein Interesse daran, es zu verbergen, wenn sie gar nichts täten.
Das ist schon richtig geil.
Also das waren schon die Maschinen, auf denen die gearbeitet haben. Also ich meine, das war eindeutig zu sehen.
Und genau das, wenn Vau jetzt sagte, es wird alles über uns gespeichert sein. Man kann ja nur speichern, was in irgendeiner Form eingebbar ist oder so. Also ich meine, es gibt wahrscheinlich bestimmte Bereiche deiner Gedanken, die nicht speicherbar sein werden.
Da muss ich dir aber gleich direkt widersprechen, aus dem ganz einfachen Grunde, dadurch, dass alle Leute andauernd irgendwas auf dem Internet rumklicken. Ich meine, ich habe selbst mit einem Kumpel einen Internet Provider aufgemacht und habe einfach nur mal so auf dem Schirm vor mir die Proxy-Protokolle vorbeilaufen sehen. Was da an Informationen schon drin steht über die einzelnen Benutzer, die diesen Proxy benutzen, das genügt schon wirklich, um die Leute, sage ich jetzt mal, ganz gezielt mit Werbung anzusprechen. Das auf alle Fälle. Im ungünstigsten Falle würde ich sagen, reicht es sogar schon, um diese Leute zu erpressen. Und das sind ja auch genau die Daten, auf die heute der Staat Zugriff nehmen möchte per Gesetz.
Da hatten wir einige Sendungen drüber zu dem Thema, zur Datenspur, die wir alle hinterlassen im Netz und so weiter. Und da gab es dann auch diesen Vergleich. Damals Volkszählung haben uns alle gegenwärt. Jetzt klicken wir alle freiwillig. Die Frage ist nur, also was ich mir manchmal überlege, ist, dass diese Daten natürlich gerade für Werbezwecke und so eine Geschichten wirklich gut verwendbar sind, aber natürlich auch enorm verfälscht sind, oder? Ich meine, wie oft hast du irgendwie die Seiten angesehen, die dich prinzipiell wirklich nicht wirklich interessieren? Einfach weil du vielleicht gesagt hast, ach guck ich mir mal an oder so. Oder, weiß ich nicht, du hast telefoniert und hast irgendwie rumgeklickt und so. Wenn jemand also ein Profil anhand dieser Daten anlegt, kann das auch kompletter Quatsch sein.
Also ich kann nur sagen, häng dich eine Woche an meinen Proxy ran und ich sag dir genau, wer du bist.
Ja, es ist aber in der werbetreibenden Wirtschaft in der Zwischenzeit so, dass die große Datenbestände miteinander abgleichen, also der Adresshandel. Um genauer zu sein, das Database-Marketing, also wo die kombinieren, bis zu mehreren hundert Datensätze über einen Haushalt. Das nimmt schon Qualitäten an. Es gibt so Sachen wie, das nennt sich Mikrogeografie, wo du ganze Straßenzüge nach dem sozialen Hintergrund, nach dem familiären Hintergrund, nach Einkunft, nach den sozialen Gegebenheiten, ist das irgendwie eine Arbeit dagegen, ist hier die Kriminalität relativ hoch und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn du solche Sachen verknüpft, was geschieht, und diese Datensätze sind auch relativ teuer, weil die Werbetreiber in der Wirtschaft dann sehr zielgenau eben ihre, nicht mehr so diese Art von Schrotzuswerbung, so diese klassischen Massensendungen noch überall hinheben, dann haben sie eben eine hohe Ausfallquote und aber die Chance irgendwie so einigermaßen diejenigen, die es auch ansprechen soll, zu erreichen.
Also ich, gibt es auch gerade einen ganz aktuellen Fall, hab leider vergessen von welcher Firma das ist, die jetzt online Versand machen auch, du bestellst online irgendwelche Sachen und die klammern tatsächlich Straßenzüge aus. Die beliefern bestimmte Straßen und Bezirke nicht, unter anderem in Berlin, weil sie sagen, da ist die Arbeitslosenquote so und so hoch, da haben wir zu viel Stress mit nicht bezahlten Rechnungen und mit Nachnahmesendungen, die wir zurückkommen. Diese Straßenzüge wohlgemerkt liefern wir nicht und das ist echt ein Hammer für mich.
Das ist eine ganze Industrie. Die ist natürlich nicht besonders daran interessiert, dass das groß in der Öffentlichkeit diskutiert wird. Es wird auch relativ wenig darüber berichtet. Und wenn, dann ist das relativ spröde, weil das irgendwie so eine Geschichte ist, ok, da ist irgendwie eine große Datenbank und so weiter. Das Problem beim Datenschutz, beim sogenannten, ist überhaupt, dass einem nichts genommen wird. Es ist sozusagen absolut unkörperlich. Es ist so ein gespenstisches, gefühlloses Ding. Also ich hab ja mal, ich heiß ja immer noch Peter Glaser, das nimmt mir ja niemand. Wenn irgendjemand sozusagen jetzt einen Datensatz, der Peter Glaser heißt, anlegt oder irgendwelche Sachen, das ist mein Geburtsdatum, das wird mir sozusagen nicht genommen. Es stellt irgendjemand eine Kopie von einzelnen Daten von mir zusammen und ich hab überhaupt kein Bewusstsein darüber. Ich hab kein Gefühl dafür, es tut mir nichts weh. Ich muss mich, ich muss etwas so aus einem tiefen Brunnen, so eine Entrüstung erstmal, so eine Art künstliche Entrüstung hochkurbeln und sagen, Moment, Moment, das gefällt mir aber nicht. Ich hab so das dunkle Gefühl, das könnte meine Souveränität irgendwie verletzen. Ich möchte das nicht.
Aber hast du nicht zumindest auch als Schriftsteller ein bisschen manchmal das Phänomen, dass sozusagen Sachen von dir durchs Netz geistern und da so ein körperloses, weites Wesen von dir entsteht, so ein Mysterium irgendwie oder ein andere Duareden. Ich meine, du hast ja auch viel in Schätz gelebt, so in der Zeit deines Lebens. Und also kennst du da nicht auch das Gefühl, dass sich deine Daten irgendwann selbstständig machen?
Ja, das gefällt mir sehr gut. Also ich bin vielleicht eine Ausnahme. Ich kann da wieder nur Wau zitieren. Die beste Möglichkeit, seine Daten zu schützen, ist sie so weit wie möglich zu verbreiten. Dann können sie nämlich am wenigsten verloren gehen. Also wenn man möchte, dass irgendetwas nicht verloren geht, dann kann man es auf dem Internet verbreiten, in der Hoffnung, dass es Leute gibt, denen das auch gefällt, die das interessant oder wichtig finden, die das kopieren und weiter verbreiten.
Aber um nochmal sozusagen zurückzukommen auf diese NASA-Zeitgeschichte, ich meine, schon damals gab es diesen Satz von dem, angeblich ein IBM-Ingenieur, soll das mal gesagt haben, der Computer ist die Antwort, was uns jetzt noch fehlt, ist die Frage.
Nee, es war ein Atari-Manager.
Naja, das kenn ich auch noch.
Und es hieß, der Computer ist die Lösung, was uns jetzt noch fehlt, ist das Problem.
Richtig. Ich meine, da arbeiten wir ja dran am Problem.
Aus der Zeit, um das Thema wieder aufzugreifen, wie wir im Prinzip sozusagen, wo sich bei uns langsam die Vision eingestellt hat, das muss zu einer Zeit gewesen sein, sage ich jetzt mal, wo, ich glaube, der C64 noch nicht ganz rausgekommen war. Was wir da ausprobiert haben, einfach ist eine Schleife, also über vorhandene Datennetze, Internet gab es damals noch nicht, also auch nicht in Ansätzen eigentlich, also funktionierend, dass wir über vorhandene Datennetze, paketvermittelte Datennetze, also hier in Deutschland Datex P und dieses ganze Giraffel, einmal eine Schleife, eine Datenverbindungsschleife um die Welt gezogen haben und uns einmal rund um die Welt sozusagen durchgewählt haben, um uns dann hier wieder selbst zu treffen mit einer Verzögerung von etwa 40 Sekunden. Da war eigentlich klar, dass das geht. Da war eigentlich auch die Vision geboren, dass das eigentlich überall gehen muss.
Ich möchte da nochmal ein bisschen fundamentaler rangehen. Das ist nämlich der Computer, ist für mich eine wichtige Universalmaschine. Eine Universalmaschine, die erste Universalmaschine in der Entwicklung war das Rad. Die nächste Universalmaschine war nach meiner Einschätzung die Uhr. Da waren fürchterlich viele Zahnräder drin und eine Unruhe mit einem Takt. Und in die Uhren können durchaus eine Ideologie haben. Im spanischen Königshaus in Madrid stehen katholische Uhren. Die haben nicht drei Zeiger, sondern in jedem Raum steht so eine Uhr. Die hat vier Zeiger. Und der vierte Zeiger ist für den katholischen Takt für den Wochentag. Und wenn ich jetzt diese Entwicklung weiter sehe von der Uhr, also so rein geisteswissenschaftlich waren auch viele Schweizer Uhrmacher als Maschine für die Industrialisierung ebenso anarchistisch drauf, weil sie sahen, hier kommt eine Maschine für die Arbeitskontrolle, für die Industrialisierung und die nächste Maschine in der Entwicklung ist einfach der Computer als Produktionsmittel. Ein riesiges Rationalisierungswerkzeug und zwar ein absolut universelles, ein generelles, mit dem man alles machen kann. Eine Universalmaschine und diese Eigenschaft, die haben wir geahnt, aber noch nicht so begriffen. Wir haben 1984 den Computer als Medium gesehen und das haben damals noch relativ wenig.
Aber hast du dir denn damals auch einen katholischen Computer vorgestellt?
Es gab ja eine katholische Programmiersprache.
Die haben die Bayern erfunden, mit einer ewigen Liste. Die ist auch noch irgendwo im Netz zu sehen.
Genau, mit einem Crucifix als Cursor. Und wenn du einen Fehler gemacht hast, ist ja eine ewige Liste gekommen.
Aber wenn ich mich hier so umgucke, stelle ich fest, dass keiner von uns eine Uhr umfasst.
Was hat das zu bedeuten, dass wahrscheinlich in zehn Jahren auch keiner von euch mehr einen Computer...
Nein, nein, das nicht. Man kann den Computer eben auch kreativ und für andere Zwecke einsetzen, außer als für Kontrolle und Überwachung. Und diese Möglichkeiten, die schöpferischen Möglichkeiten, also jetzt so der LSD-Guru, Timisi Liri, der hat sich auch sehr früh schon mit Computern beschäftigt. Und eines der ersten Spiele, als es noch eigentlich gar keine richtigen Computer gab, da hat er schon Mind Mirror gemacht, ein buntes Spiel, was kreative Gedankenmöglichkeiten ausnutzt. Also für die damalige Zeit war das irgendwie was absolut Neues, das gab es sonst kaum.
Es fiel jetzt ein paar Mal das Wort Vision. Wenn ich so zurückgucke auf viele Sendungen Chaos Radio jetzt, da gab es viele Sendungen, wo man weniger von optimistischen Visionen geredet hat, sondern eigentlich auch von Ängsten und Gefahren, die auf uns zukommen, die schon da sind, und wo man versucht, ein bisschen Licht in eine sehr dunkle Angelegenheit zu bringen. Gab es beim Chaos Computer Club, wenn ihr zurückguckt, die jetzt 20 Jahre, gab es irgendwann Zeiten, wo es alles eine optimistische Vision war, wo man gesagt hat, stell dir mal vor, das und das würde passieren, wäre das nicht großartig? Und gab es dann irgendwann Umschwung, wo man gesagt hat, was da auf uns zukommt, da habe ich ein bisschen Schiss vor, und wie sieht das heute aus?
Ich glaube, die optimistische Version, die hat darin bestanden, dass wir uns alle, jeder auf seine Art und Weise, schon relativ früh versucht haben, eine gewisse Souveränität gegenüber dieser Maschine zu verschaffen. Und das hat uns so ein Grundgefühl gegeben. Da hören jetzt gar nicht so sehr diese ganzen kritischen Gedanken, Beobachtungen, diese ganzen Überlegungen zu Datenschutz und so weiter und so fort dazu, sondern wir haben versucht herauszufinden, als noch die meisten anderen Leute sich nur irgendwie mit langen Stangen überhaupt diesen Maschinen versucht haben zu nähern, einfach so eine Maschine einzuschalten und damit rumzuspielen, ohne dass man sich überhaupt Gedanken darüber gemacht hat, was kann man damit machen, was ist das und so. Ich geh einfach mal hin, schalte es ein und gehe da rein in das Ding. Und hab dann gesehen, aha, das ist ja eigentlich irgendwie alles ein bisschen Glas und Blech und Plastik. Und hat das Ding entmystifiziert. Jemand, der wirklich ganz tief in die Technik eingestiegen ist, und hat gesehen, aha, da kann man auch nur Nullen und Einsen von links nach rechts verschieben und so geht das und so geht das. Dann weißt du, wie das Ding funktioniert. Und man lernt die Möglichkeiten kennen, dann kann man die Gefahren relativ realistisch einschätzen. Und was wir alles sehr früh herausgefunden haben, waren die Spielräume, die Spielmöglichkeiten. Das hat immer sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Aber das ist jetzt die sehr reflektierte Version, die du gerade von der optimistischen Seite präsentierst. Also ich bin ja irgendwie so 85, also vor der Einführung dieser Gesetze zum Club gekommen. Und das war für mich in der Tat damals nicht nur visionär, sondern auch sehr erprickelnd. Also das war die Zeit, wo alle wussten, ab nächstes Jahr ist es verboten. Und jetzt haben wir nochmal richtig Spaß. Und also gut, das war vielleicht auch, ich muss auch sehen, da war ja auch meine frühe Pubertät, vielleicht den Begeisterungen noch irgendwie zuträglich gleichzeitig. Aber für mich war das auch einfach ein Gefühl, darum zu sitzen, sich bei irgendwelchen Leuten privat zu Partys nachts oder wann auch immer hinzusetzen und mal irgendwie in amerikanischen Datennetzen ein bisschen spazieren zu gehen und mal die Washington Post zu lesen. Und so Geschichten, die dann per 300 irgendwie Zeichen pro Sekunde da so langsam auf den Bildschirm kamen. Und also so Geschichten, die einfach, also für mich da auch irgendwie so ein Gefühl einfach, irgendwie so ein Forschungsgefühl. Also man hat sich einfach die Geschichten angeguckt, so irgendwelche Universitäten, Firmen haben uns mehr oder weniger gesponsert, ob sie das jetzt wussten oder nicht. Also man brauchte mal so Kennungen und Geschichten. Ja, eben so dieses Jugend forscht Gefühl. Ich meine, wie gesagt, also ich fand das jetzt eben ein bisschen zu reflektiert gesprochen von dir. Also für mich war das damals ganz unreflektiertes. Ich will wissen, was da eigentlich passiert. Und boah, ist das spannend. Man macht das einen Spaß. Und was wird daraus eigentlich?
So, was ich schon gemeint.
Clubgefühl auch, oder?
Naja, das war natürlich auch ein bisschen Gruppendynamik. Klar, es hatte natürlich auch ein bisschen was trickelndes, weil es halt nicht so direkt erlaubt war. Und das war schon irgendwie eine Form von Erlebnis. Keine Ahnung, ob Leute, die heute Rollerblades fahren, irgendwie auch so einen Spaß haben oder wo da irgendwie die Dimensionen liegen.
Naja, also für mich hat es sich so dargestellt, also in erster Linie war es einfach mal total geil. Punkt, ja, weil das ist im Grunde genommen, alle möglichen Leute reden uns immer alle möglichen Motivationen ein. Und auch dieser gesamte, also ich muss jetzt sagen, für mich persönlich, ich spreche jetzt nur für mich, galt auch dieser ganze gesellschaftskritische Müll zunächst mal gar nicht. Das kam echt erst hinterher. Sondern es war einfach super. Boah, also es war eine Verlängerung. Es war im Prinzip so, wie man einen Hammer in die Hand nimmt, konnte man jetzt ein Werkzeug fürs Gehirn in die Hand nehmen, womit man also eine wesentlich, womit man plötzlich eine weltweite Reichweite erreichte, sodass man praktisch das Gehirn hat plötzlich Verlängerungen bekommen, die die ganze Welt umspannt haben. So das war im Prinzip das Gefühl, so das Gefühl, die Welt, ich bin jetzt ein schaltender und waltender Bestandteil der Welt.
Es wird langsam Zeit, mal die Telefonleitungen zu öffnen, um hier auch ein bisschen interaktiv zu agieren. Ihr könnt uns anrufen unter 0331. Ach Quatsch, wir haben doch hier diesen super Jingle.
Die Frizz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam. 70.97.110.
Ihr hört Chaos Radio, Peter Glase ist zu Gast, Vic ist hier, Vau ist da und Andy, alle vom Chaos Computer Club und alle schon sehr, sehr lange dabei. Geil, sind alle im Durchschnittsalter, es ist heute 95 hier. Stimmt natürlich nicht ganz. Was wir von euch gerne wissen möchten, ihr habt gerade so ein bisschen gehört zum Thema Motivation. Vic hat gesagt, das war einfach geil, Punkt. Hat das als Verlängerung seines Denkens empfunden, als weltumspannendes Denken plötzlich. Und hat gesagt, die ganze Gesellschaftskritische Kram, den der Chaos Computer Club ja auch bekannt ist, der kam für ihn als später dazu. Bei Andi war es bestimmt eine andere Geschichte. Was wir von euch jetzt gar nicht wissen möchten, ist, was ist eure Motivation? Was ist eure Motivation, den Computer für euch zu benutzen, das Internet zu benutzen? Was empfindet ihr dabei? Ist das eine Kopfsache? Ist das eine Bauchsache? Lebt das Ding für euch? Und so weiter und so fort. Die Nummer habt ihr gehört. Da sind auch schon Leute dran, die gleich wieder auflegen, weil sie natürlich erst jetzt die Frage gehört haben. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, das ist ein super Thema. Ich meine, das ist mittlerweile schon ein Thema für alle. Egal ob man Astronom ist oder Biologe oder ob man einfach nur Kochrezepte im Internet sammelt. Und ja, würde ich gerne auch mal drüber quatschen.
Du benutzt demnach einen Computer, benutzt das Internet?
Ja, eigentlich fast täglich. Das Ding ist, was ich sehr spannend finde, ist diese Erweiterung des Gehirns. Das ist wirklich so. Also ich empfinde es halt so, dass ich damit Sachen machen kann, die ich auf dem Blattpapier zum Beispiel nicht machen kann. Also ich studiere Gestalt mit digitalen Medien. Und insofern benutze ich täglich einen Computer. Und das ist für mich vollkommen selbstverständlich geworden. Und es ist mir auch egal, auf welchem System ich arbeite. Ob es nur Mac oder Windows oder Unix oder Amiga ist oder so. Also es spielt für mich keine Rolle mehr. Weil im Prinzip ist immer das Gleiche eigentlich.
Und inwieweit ist das für dich schon ausgereifte Technologie? Ich meine, das Ding liest ja immerhin noch deine Gedanken nicht wirklich.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Gott sei Dank dazu sagen soll. Ausgereift ist nicht. Es ist immer noch so ein bisschen Goldgräberstimmung. Und die großen Firmen, die machen ja sehr viel Werbung mit heißer Luft einfach. Also ich hab auch mal ein bisschen angefangen zu programmieren und so. Und ich weiß auch ziemlich genau, wie ein Computer funktioniert. Weil damals hatte ich auch einen C60 gehabt. Das war so 1987 hatte ich meinen ersten eigenen C60. Dann hab ich da auseinandergeschraubt und geguckt, wo die Schips liegen. Und ich war halt auch mit den Schips per Du und kannte die ganzen Adressen auswendig. Und da hat sich eigentlich auch nicht so super viel geändert, weil die Computer funktionieren ja alle eigentlich wirklich immer noch genauso. Nur, dass der Maschinencode unterschiedlich ist und verschiedene Hardware ist. Das Prinzip ist eigentlich immer das gleiche. Und ich finde das toll, dass man wirklich so viel damit machen kann, dass es eigentlich für jeden interessant ist. Deswegen finde ich es schade, dass die meisten Leute so ignorant sind. Gerade was Computer als Medium anbetrifft. Die meisten denken halt, das ist nur eine bessere Schreibmaschine oder so. Oder so ein Tabellenkalkulationsprogramm. Aber dass man in erster Linie Spaß mit dem Computer haben kann, das raffen die meisten Leute nicht. Das finde ich schade.
Naja, einem wird hier in der Schule auch nicht beigebracht, dass man mit Physik Spaß haben kann.
Ja, das stimmt. Es hängt immer von den Leuten ab, die ihn motivieren können und so. Aber das Tolle bei den Computer damals war, dass die Kids uns heute mehr Ahnung haben als die Erwachsenen. Und die waren halt so ein Kreis. Und wir hatten alle so in den C64 und haben das Software ausgetauscht.
Aber die C64-Zeiten waren ja doch eher die Baller-Zeiten, oder?
Nee, nee, nee. Gar nicht unbedingt. Also ich hatte damals schon ein ziemlich geiles 3D-Programm. Also ein kleines billiges CAD-Programm. Er hatte halt vier Stunden für so ein schäbiges 3D-Bild gerechnet. Aber man konnte schon CAD machen auf dem C64. Und sogar so, naja, so Animation und Musik und so. Also es war nicht nur bollern, es war zu Anfang. Und dann irgendwann hat man gedacht, das ist ja irgendwie primitiv, das ist mir irgendwie zu öde. Und mich haben immer so diese 3D-Welten gereizt. Und es war immer sehr lahmartig. Und auch ziemlich, naja, primitive Grafik. Einfach nur so weiße Linien auf schwarzem Grund oder so. Aber irgendwie hab ich da schon so eine Welt dahinter gesehen. Die Frage, was ist hinter dem Bildschirm? So ein bisschen wie in dem Film Tron, wo man sich fragt, ist da eine Welt? Oder wenn man so einen Text hochscrollt, wo bleibt der Text, wenn er vom Bildschirm verschwindet? Und solche Dinge, ne?
Peter Glaser hat da mal, ich weiß nicht mehr in welchem Buch, aber da hast du mal sehr schöne Sachen zugeschrieben über dieses Licht aus dem Monitor. Wo ich wirklich, es gibt ja so Sachen, die wenn man liest, dann sagt man so, stimmt, genau das ist es, was daran fasziniert, aber jemand anders kann es ausdrücken. Da war ich sehr beeindruckt von diesem, einfach auch der Unterschied zwischen Papier und diesem Monitor, selbst wenn es nur Text ist, der da drauf ist, dass das einfach leuchtet, dass das irgendwie...
Ich hab da halt eine relativ untechnische Herangehensweise und bin so ein alter Großstadtromantiker und bin immer schon so von Licht fasziniert gewesen und hatte lange Zeit und erst war das gar nicht so bewusst, meinen Bildschirm so umgestellt. Und zwar immer abends, dass ich einen schwarzen Hintergrund hatte und weiße Zeichen darauf, dass ich mich sozusagen wie so ein Kamelier und dann an die Nachtstimmung angepasst hab. Und mir so ein bisschen die... Es war sozusagen die Entfernung zwischen den Sternen und mir und dem Text und mir hat sich irgendwie nivelliert. Und ich muss dann als Schriftsteller noch dazu sagen, dass die Substanz, mit der ich arbeite, oder wenn natürlich nicht nur als Schriftsteller jeder Mensch, der denkt und jeder Mensch, der kreativ arbeitet, arbeitet mit Geist und Geist ist stopflos. Und man hat dann im Kronik genommen, wenn man das auf Material festlegt, immer wieder so eine... Also diese materielle Qualität ist schon sowas wie eine Verunreinigung. Und wenn ich jetzt am Computer das Gefühl hatte, ich schreib mit Licht, dann hatte ich das Gefühl, dass ich sozusagen so eine sehr, sehr hohe Übereinstimmung zwischen dem Denken oder so zwischen der Substanz vom Geist und der Art und Weise, wie man das ausdrücken kann, herstellt. Also nicht mal mehr Papier, sondern nur noch Licht. Das war sozusagen noch mal so ein Schritt in Richtung auf sowas wie eine Vollendung irgendwie, wenn man sich das vorstellen kann zwischen dem, was man denkt oder empfindet und dem Ausdruck.
Ich finde das irgendwie auch die materielle Komponente sehr wichtig. Also das geistige Schonhalt, man schützt vor, wie die Blitze der Gedanken, der Gedankengitz und so klar. Aber diese Reinheit, das fand ich gerade toll bei Gibson. Also das Neumanns, das erkennt jeder, der sich ein bisschen für die Cyber-Service interessiert. Und da war diese Dreckkomponente, dass die Computer einfach zerschrampft waren, dass die Monitore flackerten und so. Und bei meinen Notebooks ja auch so. Und da sehe ich jeden Tag, habe ich den Zeitlang jeden Tag mit mir rumgeschlagt, geschleppt wie so ein Baby auf dem Rücken, wo ich immer vorsichtig sein musste, damit das Ding nicht kaputt geht. Und da konnte ich halt die Bildelemente zählen, die ausgefallen sind. Aber irgendwie fand ich es eher spannend als störend. Das ist jetzt mein Computer und der hat mit mir gelebt. Und so, dass auch die Spuren des eigenen Lebens auf dem Computer hinterlassen werden.
Ich sag mal so, da gibt es auch Heilung. Ich habe gerade mal angefangen, bei mir im Innenhof jetzt Tomaten pflanzen zu pflanzen. Und das ist ein wirklich in der Tat ähnlich vergleichbar interaktives Erlebnis. Ja, das klingt jetzt irgendwie vielleicht lustig, aber ich möchte das wirklich jedem empfehlen, sich zwischendurch auch mal Enten irgendwie im Park anzugucken. Weil, ohne jetzt hier im Raum jemanden angucken zu wollen, aber ich kenne schon einige Leute, die krabbeln wirklich ein bisschen zu sehr an innen und um dem Monitor herum. Und bei denen gibt es dann auch so ein bisschen so ein gestörtes Wahrnehmungsverhältnis in Bezug auf andere Geschichten. Weil Computer, Diskussion, also gerade so diese ganzen Foren und Diskussionsmöglichkeiten übers Netz, die... Also wir haben da irgendwie auf der Autofahrt auch ein bisschen über geredet hierhin. Das ist alles irgendwie wunderbar, um sich zu zerstreiten. Aber irgendwie mit einem Computer in so einem Diskussionsforum Frieden zu schließen, ist glaube ich viel schwieriger als sich zu zerstreiten. Das Streiten geht prima. Ich meine, hast du da auch schon mal so Geschichten?
Es war damals, es ist immer so ein Grabenkrieg. Also solange ich denken kann. Damals zielten CCC eine Lächtigfraktion, die meinten, Atari ist scheiße.
Also Commodore gegen Atari.
Amiga gegen Atari. Und jetzt ist es halt im Windows gegen Mac. Das ist immer albern, weißt du? Und für mich ist ein Computer ein Medium. In meinem Wohnzimmer habe ich ein Amiga zu stehen, wo ein Mac-Emulator draufläuft. Also arbeite ich auf dem Mac und im Schlafzimmer habe ich ein Windows 95 Notebook. Und mir ist halt vollkommen wurscht, wo ich dran sitze. Weil Iris hat so seine schönen Seiten.
Ich finde aber auch...
Und ein Computer irgendwie, finde ich... Es besteht immer die Gefahr, dass man sich entfremdet von der Welt. Aber für mich ist es eigentlich eher so noch eine Erweiterung der Welt, gar kein Ersatz. Also diese Virtuality-Sache finde ich sehr spannend. Hab mich jahrelang gefesselt und da würde ich auch gerne später beruflich hingehen. Aber ich finde es immer eine Erweiterung. Sprich man letztendlich bietet einen Computer mentale Karten.
Ich glaube auch, man kann gar nicht genug computern. Also diese ganze Entfremdungsgeschichte, da mache ich mir überhaupt keine Sorgen. Weil ich weiß, es gibt eine ganz mächtige Waffe, die der Mensch sehr souverän beherrscht.
Den Ausschalter?
Nein, das ist Ignoranz. Wenn dir irgendwas zu viel wird, dann ignorierst du das einfach.
Nein, es gibt auch noch Freundinnen.
Das wäre als Alternative auch noch in Betracht.
Aber dieses Gartending, ich fühle mich immer wie so ein Bauer. Das hat sowieso Bauerqualitäten. Ich render manche 3D-Sequenzen. Ich komme abends angeritten mit einer Festplatte und gehe in die Uni und schließe an und starte einen Renderjob. Am nächsten Morgen komme ich wieder und hole meine Festplatte.
Das kannst du nicht essen.
Bei den Tomatenpflanzen kannst du zwischendurch leckere rote Dinger essen.
Das eine ersetzt es andere nicht, aber was nützt denn ein ernährter Körper, wenn dein Geist verdorrt?
Und umgekehrt gibt es das Problem auch.
Lebensqualität, weißt du?
Richtig.
Nichts gegen einen schönen Rotwein hatten wir gerade hier gehabt. Und jetzt gibt es gleich irgendwie Linsen mit Würstchen. Also alles klasse und ich will es eigentlich gegen das andere eintauschen. Aber es ist halt die Mischung macht es. So mit allen Dingen. Und wenn ich die Wahl habe zwischen Internet und Fernsehen, dann ist das Internet meilenweit vorne einfach. Es ist einfach so, du triffst da Leute, du kannst dir abends Piraten Sender angucken. Ich empfehle allen, die Tower and Base mögen, diese Pirate Radio Co UK. Das ist sehr spannend. Da gibt es auch eine Chatline. Und die spielen jeden Abend, nach unserer Zeitrechnung, ab 19 Uhr live immer DJs. Das ist ein ehemaliger Piraten Sender. Und das ist echt sehr klasse. Und die haben auch eine große Sammlung an aufgezeichneten Sessions. Und sortiert nach Stilrichtung, also nicht nur Drum und Bass. Also da entwickelt sich auch Foren, zum Beispiel, für Leute, die eigenen Musikgeschmack haben oder so. Oder halt, es gibt ja unendlich viele Foren im Internet. Von Schneckenzüchtervereinen bis Hundehassan, weiß ich ja nicht.
Jörg, du bist auch ein ganz eindeutiges Beispiel in den letzten 10 Minuten, dass Leute, die Computer benutzen, nicht kommunikationsfeindlich sind. Du hast es geschafft, mehr zu reden als wir alle zusammen. Du solltest was machen, wo du reden musst, Jörg. Vielleicht Radiomoderator, das ist immer ein ganz guter Job für solche Leute.
Ich bin mehr so ein Mann für den Hintergrund.
Ach, wer will berühmt werden? Aber ich fand diese Geschichte gerade ganz hübsch, dass du gesagt hast, mein Notebook hat auch so eine so eine materielle Qualität angenommen, einfach weil es abgeschrammt ist. Und so hättest du mal das alte Zähnnetz des Telefons von Andi sehen sollen. Dafür habe ich ihn immer schwer beneidet. So diese große Kiste, die einfach so aussah, als ob sie schon unheimlich viel erlebt hat.
Hey man, sie ist aber noch verschrammter und auch noch älter.
Der Geist ist doch nicht ohne den Körper letztendlich. Ich meine der Geist ist halt bloß der Navigator, der den Körper irgendwie durchs Leben bringt und so. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen sehr, weiß ich nicht, ein bisschen sehr esoterisch ausgedrückt.
Macht nichts. Gut, weil ich mich nochmal fragen will, das klingt alles schon so alt, weil du gesagt hast 87.
Also ich bin 80, hat mein Vater einen C64 gekauft und dann ging es halt los und so. Ja, ist halt Teil meines Lebens, aber mich interessiert in erster Linie Kunst und Musik halt. Und ich hab schon ziemlich früh, in 89, hatte ich halt meinen Amiga gehabt und dann hab ich mit Deep Paint Karteanimation gemacht, auf Video aufgezeigt, so Technosache. Oh Gott, also meine Homepage ist noch am Entstehen.
Na ja, bei uns allen so, ist kein Problem.
Okay, also ist nichts zu sehen. Allgemein kann ich, ist für alle interessant, ich bin halt an der HDK Hochschule der Künstler und wir haben einen Klassen-Server, aber der ist im Augenblick, dass die Festplatte aufgeraucht, wirklich ein wahnsinniges Wort, die wird demnächst gefixed, auf jeden Fall die Adresse ist www.digital.hdk-berlin.de Der geht nie, der geht nie. Der geht im Augenblick nicht, der geht aber so, glaub mir. Ich betreue noch nicht das Netzwerk.
Ach, guck an. Das ist so einer der Unsätze, die man auch irgendwie beim CCC immer wieder gerne feiert, wenn einer sagt, die technischen Probleme sind gelöst. Das ist für einen Unsatz.
Wir gehen im Wired-Stand, the futures are better. Es ist einfach.
Jörg, was ist deine E-Mail-Adresse?
Jomo.adk-berlin.de Jomo, J-O-M-U.
Okay, danke für deine Motivation. Das war sehr interessant.
Ja, auf jeden Fall können wir stundenlang weiter quatschen.
Aber wir wollen ja auch noch ran. Vielleicht können wir das andere auch.
Wir machen ein bisschen weiter.
So, da kann man gewisse Begeisterungen hören, möchte ich mal sagen. Ah, da hat jemand nicht durchgehalten. Über eure Motivation wollen wir auch hören. Die Telefonnummer ist 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110. Was motiviert euch, am Computer zu arbeiten, zu spielen, euch unterhalten zu lassen, selber Seiten zu bauen, das Internet zu benutzen und so weiter und so fort. Das wollen wir wissen im Chaos Radio. Darf ich sie gerade mal wieder hören? Die Chaosradio Musik kommt heute vom Analog Club DJ-Team und die könnt ihr live sehen, nämlich am kommenden Freitag ab 22 Uhr im NBI, das ist in der Schönhause Allee 8 oder am darauf folgenden Montag, ebenfalls ab 22 Uhr zusammen mit Mix Master Morris im Ex-Postamt, das ist in der Straße der Pariser Kommune 819 oder am Samstag, das ist in der 12. September mit dem Synapsenteam aus Hamburg, ebenfalls im Ex-Postamt. Straße der Pariser Kommune. Wer ist denn da dran? Es gibt dann doch Leute, die mit der Kommunikation Schwierigkeiten haben. Robert, hallo Robert. Yo, was ist denn deine Meinung? Also erst mal benutzt du einen Computer?
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ziemlich viel. Und was ich von dieser Computerwelt eben im Gegensatz zu der Nicht-Computerwelt eben halte, ist in der Nicht-Computerwelt, da fühlt man sich im Prinzip nur andauernd verarscht. Also Fernsehen, Zeitschriften, Radio, überall, was einen umgibt. Ja, man wird ja nur noch von Schott umgeben.
Geht dir das nicht im Netz auch so, speziell im WWW?
Wesentlich weniger als im Rest der Welt. Also es ist meistens immer, sagen wir mal, das Netz ist etwas weniger geldorientiert als die Außenwelt.
Nein, du kannst ja vielleicht die Bereiche aussuchen, die unkommensual sind.
Genau, also da gibt es nicht noch Bereiche, wo der ideelle Wert zählt.
Glaubst du, die werden bleiben?
Ich hoffe, dass die sich irgendwie vergrößern.
Wie seht ihr das für alle, die hier sitzen?
Also ich würde sagen, mittlerweile ist die Verarschung auch digitalisiert.
Ja gut, aber auf jeden Fall hat man irgendwie noch etwas mir ausfällt. Ich meine, es gibt irgendwie eine bestimmte Generation von Leuten, die ich auch so unter Medienmachern treffe, die einfach das Internet mit dem Fernsehen verwechseln. Und zwar auf beiden Seiten, auf der Seite der Produzenten, die irgendwie ins Netz gehen und meinen, wir sind jetzt auch im Web präsent, wir haben jetzt auch unsere Branche in das Netz gestellt und gar nicht begreifen, dass man da interaktive Kommunikation machen kann. Aber auch Leute, die eben in den Supermarkt gehen, sich eine Packung Internet kaufen und dann eben die Fernbedienung des Fernsehs mit der Maus des Computers austauschen und im Grunde genommen genau dasselbe machen, nämlich Betrachtung on demand. Also Webseiten auswählen und betrachten ist im Kern vielleicht auch nicht sehr viel anderes als Fernsehprogramme auswählen und betrachten. Aber es gibt eben im Netz immer noch sehr viel niederschwelligerer die Möglichkeit eben als Sender da reinzugehen und eben selber Sachen zu machen oder eben in Usenet Foren in einer ganz anderen Art und Weise Kommunikation zu suchen und so weiter und so fort. Insofern, ich glaube es ist eine Frage des Bewusstseins und auf jeden Fall bieten irgendwie eine Internet-Connectivity und ein entsprechender Rechner einfach mal eine andere Form von Möglichkeit. Man kann auch Betrachtung und Demand und sich verblöden. Das ist nicht so, dass einem die Verblödung irgendwie als Option nicht geliefert wurde in der digitalen Welt. Aber auf jeden Fall kann man sehr viel leichter auch ganz andere Sachen machen. Und ich glaube, das ist der entscheidende Unterschied, dass auch Leute, die wir jetzt vielleicht oder es gibt so Leute, die entwickeln ja auch Schimpansen, sichere Oberflächen und werben damit und so. Also dass auch sozusagen der Teil der Bevölkerung, der eben mit der Technik nicht unbedingt geboren wurde, jetzt sehr viel einfacher die Möglichkeit hat, damit auch mal irgendwie klarzukommen.
Oh ja, aber in der Entwicklung vergiss der Andy da leider auch noch was. Die Technologien, die uns jetzt gerade als das Ultimative vorgestellt werden, wie zum Beispiel ADSL, die haben ein Upstream-Downstream-Verhältnis von 1 zu 10.
Ja, das ist immer noch BTX 12 zu 75. Das ist schon richtig. Aber es ist immerhin schon irgendwie...
Bis sogar noch einige Größenordnungen höher, nämlich die Satelliten links, da hat man nämlich ein Upstream von 64 Kilobit und ein Downstream von 2 Megabit. Da ist das Verhältnis noch sehr viel schlechter.
Da kann man vielleicht ganz kurz für die, die jetzt sagen, haben was, da redet wir gerade davon, dass das Senden sehr viel langsamer ist als das Empfangen. Und das ist natürlich darauf ausgerichtet, dass wir dann...
Uns mit demselben Müll voll sorgen wie übers Fernsehen auch.
Also die Super Couch Potato ist als Vision sicherlich noch in den Gehirn einiger Krabattenträger verankert.
Robert, jetzt haben wir dich aber völlig unterbrochen, Entschuldige.
Ja, ich wollte im Prinzip auch da hinten raus, eigentlich, dass das Wichtige am Internet ist eben, dass man das selber macht.
Ist denn, tust du das?
Ich versuch, ja.
Meine Homepage ist noch mal in der Konstruktion.
Na ja, wird immer besser.
Das ist ja bei vielen Leuten so, man hat ja bei vielen Leuten den Eindruck, die wollen gerne eine Page bauen, aber die haben einfach nicht wirklich so Sachen, die sie interessieren.
Es gibt noch viel mehr. Ich würde am liebsten eine eigene Radio senden und alles Mögliche machen.
Robert, willst du auch deine E-Mail-Adresse ansagen? Ich finde das immer irgendwie ganz nett im Radio, wenn es jetzt Leute gibt, die denken irgendwie, ach, da würde ich denen gar noch was zu sagen oder mit denen in Kontakt treten.
Ich überleg mal.
Welche nehme ich denn?
Nehme mal walter004.gmx.de Ach, du bist das?
Ich bin da drin super, super schlecht irgendwie, weil ich gucke immer nie auf E-Mail, ich gucke nicht auf die Absender, wenn ich E-Mails kriege. Entweder sind halt Leute, die ich kenne, aber walter004 kenne ich. Walter004.gmx.de Jo, dann, weiß ich nicht, haben wir dir jetzt zu viel Wind aus den Segeln genommen?
Gut, danke.
Bis bald 23 Uhr 23 und 23 Sekunden, könnt ihr dann auch nochmal...
Wobei, was man vielleicht noch mal rausstellen sollte, ist das, also, ich finde das ein bisschen kritisch, wenn man das als Sender oder als Kommunikation im Internet, das ist das auch von einer Homepage. Also ich habe keine Homepage, ich will auch keine haben.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Ich finde, das hat auch in erster Linie was mit irgendwie, also das passt so eher zu Leuten, die sich nicht nur einen BMW kaufen, sondern dann auch ihren Schlüsselanhänger mit so einem Fuchsschwanz versehen und sich noch Spoiler dran schauen. Aber ich meine, eine Homepage heißt nichts weiter, als man präsentiert sich im Netz. Das hat nicht unbedingt gleich was mit Kommunikation zu tun.
Nein, aber es kommt immer drauf an, natürlich, ich weiß, was du meinst, eine Homepage ist natürlich nicht der Austausch, von dem wir eigentlich reden.
Darf ich mal ein paar ultimativ belehrende Worte dazu sagen?
Wir bitten darauf. Mach mal die Musik aus.
Also, es wird ja häufig, das bewegt sich alles so auf der Ebene, ich gehe in den Supermarkt und kaufe mir eine Tüte Internet. Das Internet ist nicht gleichzusetzen mit dem WWW, das möchte ich bitte noch einmal sagen, sondern der wichtigste Internetdienst für mich überhaupt ist die E-Mail. Und das WWW ist für mich ein eher unwichtiger Dienst und somit ist es auch vollkommen egal, ob man sich nun eine Homepage dahinstellt oder nicht, es sei denn, man möchte sich selbst geweihräuchern.
Das kommt immer darauf an, finde ich. Also, über dieses Thema WWW ungleich Internet haben wir hier auch schon oft geredet und ich glaube, das sollte man auch so nach den ersten zwei, drei Monaten mitgekriegt haben. Ich meine, es ist halt im Moment der Faktor, der Anteil, der beworben wird und der sagt, hier bekommen sie alles, was sie brauchen und noch viel mehr und so ein Quatsch. Vorhin hat es schon jemand den Begriff heiße Luft genannt. Newsgroups sind nach wie vor ein Kernstück, finde ich. Das sind nicht Telnetet, jemand von euch, viel?
Unbedingt, unbedingt. Ich meine, jetzt wir betreiben ja, also ich wieder mal mit einem, auch mit einem alten Clubkameraden, wir betreiben Provider in Hamburg und da brauchen wir, gut Telnet benutzen wir selten, aber SSH ist ja sowas ähnliches. Das ist so eine verschlüsselte Telnet-Verbindung im Prinzip, damit man halt Fernwartung auch ankennen wird, dann so was machen kann.
Da haben wir wieder die Hintertürchen und so, da sind wir wieder beim Sicherheitsthema, aber egal, erzähl's mal weiter.
Also ich bin eigentlich permanent auf fünf bis zehn Rechnern gleichzeitig eingeloggt und so halten das eigentlich auch die meisten anderen in meinem Umfeld. Und der Webbrowser, der langweilt sich dabei meistens eigentlich, der kommt dann so, ich würde mal sagen, etwa im Schnitt fünf bis zehn Minuten am Tag in den Einsatz.
Gut, aber du bist Techniker.
Ja, aber Wau, wie ist denn das mit dir? Du lebst doch jetzt auch schon einige Jahre in der Datenautobahn.
Haben sie da Schäden von nein, nein?
Bei dir ist es doch eher so, dass du in den Newsgroups lebst, jetzt auch mal so ein bisschen im Gegensatz zu mir, oder? Ich meine, hat sich da irgendwie dein Kommunikationsverhalten nach deiner eigenen Auffassung eigentlich eher jetzt sozusagen, ja wie soll ich sagen, multikulturalisiert? Oder was für irgendwie selbst Motivation hast du da eigentlich?
Also erst mal sehe ich es genauso. Zuerst kommt Mail, dann kommt noch mal Mail, dann kommt noch mal Mail und dann kommen die Newsgroups. Und da bin ich aus Zeitgründen im Moment bei einem relativ beschränkten Sortiment, weil für jeden Menschen hat der Tag nur 24 Stunden. Und wenn man dann noch sehr intensive private Mails schreibt, im Bereich von mehreren Stunden am Tag, weil man sich verliebt hat, dann macht man im Rest halt weniger. Aber was für mich das Wichtigste ist, das ist der Zugang zum Wissen. Und da hat sich für mich in den letzten Jahren sehr viel getan. Eine Fülle vom Wissen der Welt liegt nur noch ein paar Mausklicks entfernt. Und das finde ich eine wunderschöne Sache im Vergleich zu den Bibliotheken, wo man hinrennen muss, wo dann ein Buch vergriffen ist oder so. Und die Kopierbarkeit der Information macht vielen Menschen auf einen Schlag den Zugriff möglich. Und das muss noch weiter ausgebaut werden. Aber das ist eigentlich schon... Also Deutschland hing dahinter her, weil die Politik das nicht geschnallt hat. Aber es geht doch durchaus voran, finde ich da.
Kann ich da kurz eine politische Zwischenfrage stellen? Gibt es denn... Also ich will jetzt nicht von euch im Einzelnen wissen, wen ihr wählt oder so, aber ich hatte neulich die Diskussion. Wird ja im Moment versucht, viel politisch heimlich, finde ich, durchzusetzen, um in irgendeiner Form eine Kontrolle zu erreichen, im Netz, übers Netz, über einzelne Bereiche des Netzes. Gibt es parteipolitisch irgendwas, wo ihr sagt, da gibt es tatsächlich Leute, die sich scheinbar besser damit auskennen und näher beschäftigen als das, was man so in der Tagespresse liest?
Klar ist nein.
Ich sag das mal ganz klar. Eine Partei, die sich für das, was wir 1985 gefordert hatten, einsetzt, die würde ich wählen und das war die maschinenlesbare Regierung. Den Zugang zu den Daten, die für Staat und Gesellschaft wichtig sind. Dass die Bürger da rankommen. Und die Partei, die das macht, die kann man wählen. Und das tut gegenwärtig eigentlich keiner.
Also ich könnte jetzt höchstens belustigend hinzufügen, wir haben ja auch schon darüber diskutiert, eine Partei zu gründen. Hier in Berlin hatten wir mal diese Erwägung. Wir sind über den Flohmarkt spaziert und da hat jemand so CCCP-Wimpel verkauft von den Russen damals. Und da wollten wir spontan die Chaos Computer Club Partei gründen und haben auch ganz schnell wie ein Wahlprogramm uns aus den Fingern gesogen. So Maßnahmen gegen organisierte Kriminalität, Legalisierung aller Drogen, die Atomkraftwerke alle 300 Meter unter die Erde. Und ach, das haben wir uns nicht alles ausgedacht. Aber irgendwie hat uns dann doch die Motivation verlassen. Und ich glaube, Parteipolitik kommt bei mir irgendwie in der Gewichtung der wichtigen Dinge im Leben so hinter Mehl und Tomatenpflanzen. Also dermaßen weit hinten, da sollten wir lieber mehr Musik hören.
Jetzt diskutieren wir schon offline.
Was sagt ihr online?
Sind wir gerade in der WWW Ja oder Nein Diskussion angekommen und auch bei der Frage ist das Internet beziehungsweise spezielle Dienste wie E-Mail und Newsclubs eigentlich die Renaissance des Wortes. Ich stelle fest, dass je mehr ich das Internet benutze, was ja immer auch schon eine Weile ist, möchte ich mal betonen, auch wenn es nicht seit 20 Jahren ist, sondern auch nicht seit 15, seitdem schreibe ich viel, viel mehr als je in meinem Leben zuvor. Ich war ein super schlechter Briefeschreiber, aber die Möglichkeit, ich habe irgendwann auch gemerkt, was mich daran nervt, nämlich ich schreibe was, ich muss es eintüten, ich muss es abschicken und wenn es ankommt, ist es schon wieder eigentlich längst vergangen. Und die Möglichkeit, diese Worte oder Gedanken auch ganz kurz und kurzfristig dem anderen mitzuteilen, irgendwie hat mich dazu getreten, dass ich jetzt doch irgendwie jeden Morgen so mindestens ein, zwei Stunden sitze und Mails beantworte und trotzdem einen ganzen Haufen nicht schaffe.
Es gibt einen Begriff im Englischen, der eines der maßgeblichen Erfolgsrezepte von Internet, und in seinen Diensten bezeichnet, der ist Convenience, Bequemlichkeit, mit einem deutschen Satz gesagt, Faulheit siegt. Das ist ein maßgeblicher Teil des Erfolgsrezepts vom Internet. Das heißt, was du sagst, ist, du brauchst nicht mehr, wenn du irgendwie eine Eingebung hast. Ich hab einen Freund, der wohnt auf den Philippinern, ist ein alter Freund von mir, mit dem war ich bei den Pfadfindern, der hat so irgendwie auf die andere Seite des Globus verstrahlt. Und dem schreibe ich jetzt manchmal zwei, drei Zeilen, die mir gerade einfallen. Das ist was, was ich, dazu würde ich keinen Brief schreiben. Eintüten, eine Briefmarke draufkleben und hoffen, dass er irgendwie in drei Wochen auf den Philippinern ist. Auf die Art und Weise kann ich meinen Freund an meinem Alltag wieder teilnehmen lassen, so aufgrund, indem ich ihm auch so kleine Schnipsel und andere Sachen mir irgendwie zukommen lassen. Wir tauschen uns auf die Art und Weise wieder viel intensiver, unsere alte Freundschaft auf die Art und Weise wieder aktiviert. Richtig. Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, es hat nicht nur Vorteile, diese Möglichkeit zur Spontaneität, die E-Mail gibt, die haut auch ein bisschen auf den Stil. Das heißt, wenn man nicht vorher schon ein bisschen Übung und Disziplin mitgebracht hat im Formulieren oder in dem Bedürfnis, jetzt irgendwas ein bisschen auszuformulieren, vielleicht noch mal drauf zu gucken, bevor man es irgendwie gleich wegschießt, führt dazu, dass es dann viel schlechtgeschriebenes kommt, viel Sachen, die einfach nicht viel mehr spontan sind.
Ich finde dieses Wort Stil extrem wichtig und da kann man vielleicht auch noch mal den Begriff Netiquette ins Rennen werfen. Ich finde das ganz spannend, weil ich verschiedenste E-Mails bekomme und beantworte, unter anderem natürlich von Fritz-Hörern und Fritz-Hörerinnen und so und speziell bei Leuten, die wie wir alle, also zum ersten Mal irgendwie im Netz waren und das gemacht haben, war das alles unheimlich aufregend und da ist Stil durchaus nicht zu vernachlässigen. Also es gibt zwei verschiedene Arten von ganz grausamen Mails. Die einen sind die, die auf die Spontanität des Mediums so reagieren, dass ich Mails bekomme, wo drinsteht, was war denn das für ein Song? Mehr nicht. Wo man dann irgendwie so, man, also erstmal wäre so ein Hallo nett und vielleicht auch Tschüss Tobias oder was auch immer. Ist einfach nett, wenn man so einen Brief öffnet, dann weiß man, man wird ein bisschen angesprochen und man weiß auch mit wem man gerade kommunizieren soll, will, muss, wie auch immer und so spontan, wie man es abschickt, kommt es halt dann doch nicht an. Insofern kann es sein, dass man das ersten Tag später liest. Ich weiß also dann nicht, was das gerade für ein Song war. Und das andere Extrem sind Mails mit 52 Kilo Beide und endlose Lebensgeschichten, die man wirklich einfach, allein davon, dass sie nicht einen Absatz haben, irgendwie extrem schwierig lesen kann. Also als kleiner Tipp an euch, Kurz schreiben ist super, Hallo sagen ist auch super, Tschüss sagen ist einfach nett. Und ja, ansonsten einfach mal unter irgendeiner Suchmaschine nach dem Begriff Netiquette suchen. Und dann findet man eine ganze Menge interessantes Material.
Eine Sache steht da allerdings noch nicht drin, die man unbedingt noch hinzufügen sollte zur E-Mail Netiquette, nämlich bitte verschmutzt eure Mail nicht mit HTML-Code.
Oh ja, das ist auch eine schlimme Angewohnheit. Schlimm, einfach Texte schreiben reicht. Reicht uns allen. So, Klugschiss gibt's gleich weiter, nämlich nach dem Fritz-Kurz-Info, was gleich folgt. Zwei Leute sind hier schon eine ganze Zeit in der Leitung. Wenn ihr durchhaltet, dann seid ihr auch gleich nach dem Info dran. Ihr hört Chaos Radio jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat bei Fritz, der Computer-Blumon, im weitesten Sinne, denn es geht natürlich nicht nur um die Maschinen, sondern auch um die Menschen, die davor sitzen. Und heute mit dem Chaos Computer Club in Form von Andy, Vau, Vic und Pizza Glaser. Musik heute Abend, nach wie vor vom Analog Club DJ-Team und wann die zu sehen sind, sag ich dann im Laufe der Sendung auch nochmal, denn das hatte ich euch vorhin schon gesagt.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 23 Uhr 32.
Jetzt, Krisentreffen vor dem Hintergrund des dramatischen Rubelverfalls, ist der amtierende russische Ministerpräsident Tschernomyrdin mit dem Chef des Internationalen Währungsfonds zusammengekommen. Beide trafen sich am Abend auf der Schwarzmeer-Halbinsel Krim. Im Tagesverlauf hatte der Rubel weiter dramatisch an Wert verloren. Entgegenkommen, die libysche Führung hat sich positiv zu dem Kompromissvorschlag der USA und Großbritanniens zur juristischen Aufarbeitung des Lockerbie-Anschlags geäußert. Er sieht vor, dass den beiden mutmaßlichen libyschen Attentätern in den Niederlanden der Prozess gemacht wird. Bei dem Anschlag auf eine US-Pajaziermaschine waren im Dezember 88 über dem schottischen Lockerbie 270 Menschen getötet worden. Kritik, die scheidende Ausländerbeauftragte des Bundes Schmalz-Jakobsen, hat der Politik Versäumnisse bei der Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus vorgeworfen. Angesichts gewalttätiger Übergriffe und einer wachsenden Zahl von Anhängern rechter Gruppen hätte sich der Bundestag intensiv mit diesem Thema beschäftigen müssen. Unwetter, der Hurricane Bonnie hat die Ostküste der USA erreicht. Die Sturmfront hat eine Breite von 640 Kilometern. Für North und South Carolina sowie Virginia ist der Notstand ausgerufen worden. Etwa eine halbe Million Menschen haben sich ins Landesinnere in Sicherheit gebracht.
Das Lied My Bonnie is over die Orphen bekommt auch plötzlich andere Züge oder?
Fußball Bayern München hat sich als zweiter deutscher Club die Hauptrunde der Champions League gesichert. Nach dem 4 zu 0 Hinspielsieg schafften die Bayern im Rückspiel der zweiten Qualifikation Runde bei Oberlich-Belgrad ein 1 zu 1 Unentschieden.
Wetter!
Abends und Nachts einzelne Schauer 10 bis 7 Grad, morgen dann wechselhaft Temperaturen bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr!
A13 in Richtung Berlin zwischen Schwarzheide und Klettwitz. Stau nach einem Verkehrsunfall, bitte ab Schwarzheide die U25 nutzen.
Ein Fritz Kurz Info mit Gerätköter Heinrichs.
Ein viel geschmiertes Jahrzehnt. Diese Woche in voller Länge bei Fritz. Mit allen Entgleisungen wie... Karottenjeans, New Romantic, Dirty Dancing, Lederkrawatten, NDW und anderen Bemerkenswürdigkeiten. Diese Woche, jeden Tag, von morgens bis abends.
Ihr hört nach wie vor Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Mit Andi, mit Vau, mit Vic, mit Peter Glaser und mit Johnny am Mikrofon. Der übrigens gerade jetzt aus dem WWW-Chat ausgestiegen ist, weil diese Version vom WWW-Chat nämlich die Usernamen nicht schützt. Also das heißt, es gibt dann immer die unheimlich witzigen Leute, die reinkommen und unter dem Namen Johnny zum Beispiel, den ich hier benutze im Chat, dann irgendwie lauter Müll verzapfen. Das ist so eine Geschichte, die Zehnjährige immer wieder fasziniert. Das ist auch okay, wenn man ganz frisch dabei ist. Haben wir kein Problem. Mit jedenfalls wollte ich nur sagen, dass von mir jetzt im Chat nichts mehr kommt. Insofern ist alles, was hinter diesem Namen steht, Schrott. So, schauen wir doch mal, ob die Hörer durchgehalten haben. Der hat nicht durchgehalten. Hast du durchgehalten? Natürlich. Na super. Wer bist du denn? Kai Uwe, hallo. Aus Dresden? Benutzt du ein Computer?
Ich benutze Computer, natürlich.
Und hast du irgendeine Vorstellung davon, wo ich mich gerade befinde, während ich mit dir rede?
Nicht im WWW-Bund.
Nee, aber unterm Zwischwald. Ich hab mir einen Stift runtergefallen, ist Entschuldige. Was motiviert dich daran, deinen Computer zu benutzen, irgendwie dich da ranzusetzen, täglich, weiß ich, wie viele Stunden, musst du mal erzählen, irgendwie dich da vorzusetzen?
Ja, es gibt Tage, da besitzt man halt auch schon seine 12, 14 Stunden vorm Rechner.
Arbeitest du damit?
Aber auch für einen Beruf. Nicht in Anwendung, sondern ich berechne mehr. Alles, was in Sachen Elektronik ist und ja, noch super kleine andere Dinge.
Du springst also viel mit Zahlen rum?
Ich spring sehr viel mit Zahlen rum.
Und tut sich da, ist das eine Welt für dich? Wenn wir so, haben wir einen Hörer gehabt, ich glaube Robert Wars, der so gesagt hat, also die Computerwelt und dann die echte Welt, so der hat da ganz strikt unterschieden. Ist das für dich auch so oder?
Nein, man kann das glaube ich zusammenführen. Das ist auch das Gute bei den Rechnern. Man kann in der normalen Welt als auch in der Computerwelt halt seine Dinge machen, die man will. Zwar nicht anonym, aber es geht halt.
Du führst ja als Person Dinge auch nicht anonym aus, oder? Wenn du zum Bäcker gehst und Brötchen kaufst.
Nee, das nicht. Aber alles, was im Internet ist, ist doch schon sehr anonym.
Also nicht glücklich.
Ja, eigentlich schon. Also wenn ich das gerade von euch gehört hab, dass ich Leute unter euren Namen einloggen.
Okay, aber ich könnte mich natürlich jetzt auch ransetzen und versuchen, die IPs rauszukriegen von den Leuten und so weiter. Also das wäre alles nicht unmöglich. Ja, ich kann auch einen Chat ausmachen.
Im Zeitalter von ISDN und digitalen Datenübertragung kein Problem mehr.
Ist auch das Gute.
Aber ich find's trotzdem immer wieder erschreckend im Internet. Weil sich da doch an gemeinen Fußvolk möges von extrem rechts kommen oder von pervers veranlagten Leuten rumtummelt. Das ist das, was mich im Internet immer wieder erschreckt.
Und findest du das im Fernsehen besser?
Im Fernsehen ist es genau nicht so besser. Aber ich sag mal, als das Internet noch frisch war, oder vor 5, 6 Jahren, wo ich das erste Mal drin war, war es halt doch noch mehr kleiner in die Gemeinde. Leute, die zusammengehalten haben. Wenn man da eine Mail geschrieben hat und eine Frage hatte, hat man halt auch eine Antwort gekriegt.
Das ist natürlich, also das ist ja in Newsgroups immer noch so, finde ich. Aber du hast natürlich damit ein Thema angesprochen, was ich eigentlich auch den CCC mal fragen wollte. Entwicklung im Internet, Veränderung der sozialen Struktur. Das ist natürlich ein Problem, mit dem man jetzt umzugehen hat und wo man irgendwie eine ganze Menge, glaube ich, Toleranz zeigen muss und irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, so wie man selber als Neueinsteiger damals Tipps bekommen hat, muss man jetzt Leuten Tipps geben und so. Aber was du ansprichst, ist, dass es natürlich eine lange Zeit eine sehr elitäre Geschichte war und damit auch eine Geschichte, die auf einem, sagen wir mal, ich wollte eigentlich sagen relativ hohen Level, aber ich sag mal anderen Level stattgefunden hat, als wenn es plötzlich zu einem Massenmedium wird.
Und das nimmt aber immer mehr ab mit der Zeit. Also wenn man heute mal in Manstein Webchat reinguckt und wie sich die Leute dort mit Wörtern beschmeißen.
Ich finde, das ist eher die kurze Version von der Lage, die du da schilderst. Die kurze Version lautet, die Stimmung steigt, das Niveau sinkt. Und das stimmt auch sicherlich. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja nicht so, dass die qualifizierten Kommunikationsteilnehmer das Netz verlassen haben oder jetzt alle nur noch Tomatenpflanzen züchten oder was auch immer tun. Sondern die Wahrheit ist, sie sind immer noch da und es ist natürlich irgendwie ein Kampf der Argumente. Aber letztendlich hängt es auch davon ab, dass du vielleicht diese Leute mehr suchen musst und auch letztendlich durch die Präzision der Fragen, mit der du an das Medium herangehst, auch erst die Präzision der Antworten heute bekommst. Früher mag das einfacher gewesen sein, aber das halte ich auch in Ansätzen für Gericht. Also ich weiß schon auch, wir hatten früher irgendwie sehr viel mehr Spaß, weil wir haben uns auch, also das war auch immer so ein bisschen eine Geschichte, die den Club vielleicht ausgemacht hat. Wir waren zwar in allen Weltnetzwerken unterwegs, aber wir haben uns auch einmal die Woche im wirklichen Leben in diesem sogenannten getroffen und wussten halt so ungefähr, wie die Leute auch irgendwie drauf sind, wer jetzt irgendwie hippie und wer Punk ist und wer ein Porsche fährt und wer irgendwie eine Freundin hat oder was auch immer. Und also man konnte sich irgendwie als Mensch da noch ein bisschen so einschätzen und das ist natürlich jetzt ein bisschen verloren gegangen. Und das heißt, dass man letztendlich mehr Gehirnschmerz und mehr Tastaturfragen da reinsetzen muss, um das irgendwie zu erfahren von anderen.
Ich meine, das mit den Anspruchs, mit der anspruchsvollen Gemeinschaft, also zwei Seiten, es gab zu den früheren Seiten, mir fällt eine Person dazu ein, Clifford Stoll, so ein Astronom, Wissenschaftler, der die Netzgemeinschaft immer verteidigt hat. Oder das, was er als die Netzgemeinschaft angesehen hat, er sagte, die Computernetze, da sind hauptsächlich Wissenschaftler drin unterwegs und das ist eine große Gemeinschaft. Und dann kommen so blöde Hacker und wollen alles kaputt machen. Und da hat es sich ja auch so als Hackerjäger ein bisschen profiliert. Und wenn solche Leute wieder Stoll recht behalten hätten, dann wären die Netze oder das, was jetzt das Internet ist, immer noch eine geschlossene Veranstaltung, die irgendwie ein paar hochsubventionierten Akademikern vorbehalten wären. Und es gäbe noch keine Spur von der Demokratisierung, davon, dass halt jeder oder immer mehr Leute jetzt Zugang zum Netz haben. Und da muss man dann sich fragen, oder man muss das einfach mit in Kauf nehmen, dass irgendwie möglicherweise das Niveau sinkt oder das, was man halt selber irgendwie für das Niveau hält, oder dass eine größere Bandbreite an Ausdrucksmöglichkeiten, um das jetzt mal nicht zu bewerten, irgendwie stattfindet. Wenn so die Wengl-Schleusen geöffnet werden und so Leute wie der Stoll seine Auffassung, die ich für sehr elitär halt nicht weiter vertreten können, sondern wenn man sagt, Gemeinschaft ist schon in Ordnung, aber wenn, dann soll das sozusagen die Gesamtgemeinschaft umfassen und alle von diesen Möglichkeiten partizipieren. Letzter Satz dazu, das Internet, das ja jetzt in der Zwischenzeit auch fast 30 Jahre alt ist, ist stets aus öffentlichen Mitteln finanziert worden und von diesen Netzen wusste die Öffentlichkeit, die das Geld dafür gegeben hat, aber 20 oder 25 Jahre lang nicht.
Das ist ein super interessantes Thema, finde ich, denn als ich eingestiegen bin, war das noch eine sehr elitäre Geschichte und ich fand das unglaublich spannend, dass da Leute sich darüber unterhalten haben. Wir haben hier ein großartiges Medium, wir müssen das verbreiten, das muss populär sein, um eine wirkliche Demokratisierung zu erreichen, muss jeder Zugang dazu haben, wenn er das auch nicht privat hat, dann irgendwo öffentlich, aus den von Peter gerade genannten Gründen. Und dann findet das jetzt langsam statt, vielleicht nicht auf die Art und Weise, wie wir es uns gewünscht haben, aber es findet statt, diese Verbreitung, diese Popularisierung und jetzt stellt man dann plötzlich fest, dass ein Chat eben teilweise aus Grund besteht. Aber das ist eine Geschichte, mit der man ja auch im alltäglichen Leben umgehen muss. Du suchst ja auch deine Gesprächspartner, mit denen du dich abends triffst in der Kneipe oder bei dir zu Hause, die suchst du dir ja auch aus. Und so musst du das natürlich auch im Internet tun, was auf Dauer nichts anderes als eine Reflektion sein wird. Ja, Leute, die es benutzen.
Aber viele dieser Leute sind ja heute auch schon wieder auf dem Standpunkt, dass sie sagen, es hätte vielleicht doch nicht solche Antworten annehmen dürfen.
Ja, aber gut, ich meine, was wäre denn die Alternative zu sagen? Also ich meine, willst du einen Aufnahmetest fürs Internet haben?
Also dazu muss ich auch, da kann ich auch wieder was Grundsätzliches Internetführerschein zusagen. Also Demokratie führt in letzter Konsequenz ohnehin zur Diktatur der Idioten. Und das ist in allen Lebensbereichen das Gleiche. Das sieht man ja auch in der Politik. Und zu der Frage, wie es früher früher war, alles viel schöner und viel besser und die Leute waren viel qualifizierter. Das hat eine ganz simple Ursache. Man musste früher wissen, auf welcher Seite der Lötkolben heiß ist. Man musste wissen, welche Frequenzen der Akustikkoppler piept. Und man musste wissen, was ein Terminal-Programm tut, um überhaupt den Kontakt herstellen zu können. Und das schließt natürlich eine sehr große Personengruppe schon mal aus. Was bedeutet, dass eigentlich nur diese Personengruppe, die das kann, dazu überhaupt den Zugriff hat und dort auch nur zum Sprechen kommt? Nun wird es halt, sag ich jetzt mal, nun wird das Internet quasi, was ja auch schön ist, auch von, also wie soll ich sagen, nicht nur von Dumpfbacken überflutet, sondern es kommen eben auch neue Gesichtspunkte. Es können nämlich zum Beispiel jetzt mittlerweile auch Künstler mit ihren Macs daran teilnehmen, was ich persönlich als Bereicherung empfinde. Leider, ja, so ist es eben in der gesamten menschlichen Gesellschaft gibt es ein Bild, ist es praktisch ein eins zu eins Abbild dessen, was die Menschen denken, fühlen und leben.
Ja, aber das muss ja nicht in einer Diktatur der Idioten ausarten. Das heißt ja, etwas neutraler ausgedrückt, dass sozusagen das Bewusstsein des überwiegenden Teil des Bevölkerungen immer noch relativ ausschlaggebend im Bezug auf die Konsequenzen ist und dass wir an den Parameter schrauben müssen, dass es ja nun auch nichts Neues ist.
Nein, man kann schon ehrlich sein, es ist immer wieder erschreckend, was einem irgendwie entgegenkommt. Ich will mal ein Beispiel nennen, im Zusammenhang mit E-Mail oder mit Texten, die Leute im Internet jetzt öffentlich von sich geben, in den Newsgroups und so weiter. Mir ist irgendwann mal aufgefallen, ich dachte mir, haben die Kulturpessimisten recht? Ich bin überhaupt kein Kulturpessimist. Ich glaube, dass alles irgendwie immer besser und wunderbar wird und dass die Leute immer krüger und schöner werden. Aber dann sah ich da die Leute, ich dachte mir irgendwie, okay, die Alphabetisierung geht zu Ende, der Analphabetismus verbreitet sich, die Leute können immer schreiben. Da waren Texte, wo ich mir dachte, haben die Leute das mit Boxhandschuhen irgendwie geschrieben. Das war irgendwie Legasthenie hoch drei, jedes dritte Wort falsch und so weiter und so fort. Und ich bin dann nach längerem Nachdenken zu dem Schluss gekommen, es ist ein Teil Schlamperei und es ist vielleicht wirklich ein Teil schlechte Autografie, schauderhafte Bildung und es ist aber durch das Internet ein Medium da, wo das zum ersten Mal auf diese erschreckende Art und Weise sichtbar wird. Das war möglicherweise schon lange so. Es ist nicht eine Verschlechterung, aber es ist einfach sichtbar geworden und zwar Leute, die nicht schreiben wollen oder nicht können oder selber merken, ich habe irgendwie Probleme mit dem Ausdruck, ich habe irgendwie so eine gewisse Autografie-Schwäche und so weiter. Die können das sozusagen in einem Medium, in dem sie sich nicht schriftlich ausdrücken müssen. Dem können sie ausweichen. Dann machst du eben Sport oder machst irgendwas anderes. Du musst ja nicht unbedingt schreiben und im Internet, das ist aber jetzt so, dass das ein Medium ist, in dem die zentrale Ausdrucksmöglichkeit immer noch das Schreiben ist. Da kommst du sozusagen nicht drum rum und dann werden solche Sachen sichtbar. Und das ist dann einfach ein Stück gesellschaftlicher Wirklichkeit. Das ist irgendwie erschreckend. Das ist auch nochmal was anderes, wie zum Beispiel Talkshows im Fernsehen, wo einfach so ein gewisser Zynismus vorherrscht, wo eine Struktur da ist, die einfach die Naivität von Leuten ausnutzt. Und das ist dieses altrömische Brot und Spiele, wo Leute in eine Situation gebracht werden, wo sie irgendwie Intimitäten ausplaudern oder Affekte irgendwie angereizt werden. Das würden die sich irgendwie nicht mal im Schlafzimmer, irgendwie würden EE-Bauer nicht mehr darüber reden. Also so ist das Internet, da kann ich dann auch nur dem zustimmen, was Vicky gesagt hat letztendlich, das ist eine Abbildung von dem, was wir in der Wirklichkeit haben. Und bestimmte Dinge sieht man halt deutlich, Werner.
Also Newsgroup-Beiträge sind im Durchschnitt im Grunde genommen auch nicht schlimmer als das, was man bei McDonald's an der Kasse beiläufig hört.
Kommt auf den Newsgroup an. Ich darf den Durchschnitt. Robert? Ach Quatsch, nicht Robert.
Klaus Babel.
Klaus Jürgen war's?
Ach damn, die Doppelnamen.
Da hast du uns wieder. Ich finde, was Will grad gesagt hat mit den Künstlern irgendwie, das ist halt auch nicht ganz unwichtig. Weil es gibt ja auch Leute, die auf eine sehr kreative Art und Weise mit diesen Problemen umgehen. Und zum Beispiel, es gibt durchaus sehr durchdachte auch WWW-Sites, die dafür sorgen, dass man doch viel lesen muss, um überhaupt Zugang dazu zu bekommen. Und ich finde, das führt irgendwann wieder zurück zu diesem Mailbox-Prinzip. Also irgendwann geht man wieder dazu über, dass man bestimmte abgeschlossene Bereiche hat, wo man halt vielleicht so kleine Clubs gründet oder so. Und weiß ich nicht, ich glaube, das ist eine Entwicklung, die in den nächsten Jahren noch sehr spannend sein wird.
Aber es gibt doch zu viele WWW-Seiten, die einfach falsch an dem Obst sind.
Ja, aber die muss man ja nicht angucken.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir eine WWW-Seite aufbrennen muss, in einem Gymnasium oder in einer Mittelschule, ich sag mal, die anderen gehen dem Netz eigentlich nicht viel verloren. Um vorzustellen, welche Fascia sie unterrichten.
Das finde ich echt einen schwierigen Satz.
Die haben nichts verloren.
Das ist echt einfach extrem intolerant.
Die Welt besteht aus einer Menge von persönlichen virtuellen Realitätswahrnehmungen. Und jeder hat da irgendwie seinen Bereich und du hast ja gerade im Internet noch eher die Möglichkeit andere Leute auszublenden als im wirklichen Leben oder als im Fernsehen. Ob das gut oder schlecht, das will ich gar nicht bewerten. Aber ich finde es echt komisch, dass du dich über Sachen aufregst, die du so wunderbar ignorieren kannst, sogar mit ohne Mausklick. Also ich finde, da solltest du mal wieder über Tomaten pflanzen oder ähnliches nachdenken, um erstmal wieder ein entspanntes Verhältnis dazu zu gewinnen.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man sagen, das Netz ist eigentlich eine Bereicherung für die Allgemeinbildung.
Wir bedanken uns für diese doch eher kulturoptimistische Abschluss.
Das ist ja wirklich so. Ich meine, wenn man was sucht, früher, als man in die Bibliothek gegangen hat, sich drei Stunden an irgendwelchen Computern über irgendwelche Bücher informiert, die eh alle schon vergriffen sind und heute sucht man halt was und...
Es geht einfach darum, als du dir die suchen, du musst dir einfach diese Sachen rauspicken, die du okay findest, die Sachen. Ich meine, das tust du im täglichen Leben. Also du kaufst eben die BZ oder eben nicht. So einfach ist das.
Genau, heutzutage kann man das, was man nicht findet, im Internet suchen.
Sagt ihr schon mal Tschüss, ja? Ihr hört Chaos Radio bei Fritz. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat sitzen wir hier mit immer verschiedensten Mitgliedern von Chaos Computer Club, unterhalten uns über Computer, manchmal über technische Themen, manchmal über Hardware, selten über Software eigentlich und immer gerne auch über das, was diese Geräte anrichten und zwar nicht unbedingt in Hardware Richtung, sondern in soziale Richtung. Da haben wir schon eine Menge zu gehört. Zu Gast heute sind Andi vom CCC, Vau, Vick und Peter Glaser. Das sind...
Die Rentner.
Sag doch mal euer Alter durch, bitte.
Äh, Peter Glaser, 41.
Vick, 34, glaube ich.
Ich bin Jahrgang 51.
Ach, das muss man wieder rechnen, Vau. Du bist ein Freund von Zahlen.
Sei froh, dass er sein Alter nicht im Oktal-System anbietet.
Ich bin 26, Andi.
Guck mal an, ihr seht alle viel jünger aus.
Vau ist Stubenältester.
Aber nicht unbedingt stupereit.
Wir haben gerade ein bisschen über Motivation geredet. Gibt es denn, gab es für einen von euch irgendwann mal einen Punkt, ich meine, ihr habt euch jetzt ewig damit beschäftigt und vorhin viel, viel auch so der Satz, ich lebe damit, das ist Teil meines Lebens, das ist halt so, so wird uns das wahrscheinlich allen gehen. Gab es irgendwann mal einen Punkt, wo irgend einer gesagt hat, ich will die Scheiße nicht mehr sehen, ich schmeiße den Computer raus und...
Immer wieder, das kommt hin, weil, das gehört so natürlich sozusagen dazu, dass man so einen Übertrost oder so eine, man überfräst sich an Informationen, genauso wie man sich so an stopflichen, an Nahrungsmitteln oder an, ich bin zum Beispiel ein passionierter Bahnfahrer und ich setze mich immer in den Speisewagen und weil ich Österreicher bin und da sozusagen das Kaffeehaus-Prinzip noch mal perfektioniert wird, ich trinke meinen Kaffee und draußen schiebt jemand einen langen Stang an die Landschaft vorbei, das ist einfach herrlich, das ist so die archaische Form von Fernsehen und ich merke aber auch so, das ist wirklich, das gehört zu den schönsten und wunderbarsten Dingen, die ich mir überhaupt vorstellen kann und trotzdem bin ich irgendwann satt, nach vier oder fünf Stunden kann ich nicht mehr gucken. Also dann bin ich voll, dann rennt es mir bei den Augen und bei den Ohren wieder raus und so ist es mit allem, so ist es mit, wenn man sich irgendwie am Montag hinsetzt und sich einen ganzen Tag Zeit nimmt und den Spiegel durchliest, dann hat man auch am Ende beim Spiegelohren hin immer das Gefühl, so ich stürze mich jetzt aus dem Fenster, es geht zum Ende zu, es ist irgendwie alles gleich vorbei und das muss jetzt...
Aber bei der Zizanik hat man in Anung alles ist scheiße.
Genau.
Und das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht nur unbedingt negativ, sondern einfach, es gab mal so ein Grunderlebnis, als ich das erste Mal sozusagen an einem Internetrechner war, an der MCS, Gott hab sie selig, die erste Internet, der erste Internetzugang in Hamburg, den ein Freund von uns gemacht hat und als ich, da hatte ich dann einen Account, da bin ich dann Teilnehmer geworden und war sehr stolz drauf und da bin ich mal zwei Wochen nicht reingegangen und als ich dann wieder hinkam, hatte ich die Meldung, hallo Peter Klaas, es liegen 37.811 u-Gelesene Meldungen für dich vor. Da hat dann nämlich noch alle einzelnen Newsgroups, die einzelnen Nachrichten sozusagen durchgezählt. Dann hab ich einen Schock gekriegt. Dann wusste ich jetzt, jetzt, jetzt beginnt eine neue Zeit. Jetzt muss ich mir irgendwas überlegen. Jeder von uns hat seine Lösung dann gefunden, vor dieser ist sozusagen Don Quijote auf die Windmühle losgeritten. Ein Freund von uns, Ex-Rom, der hat das Problem konsequent gelöst, er hat sich immer größere Festplatten gekauft, der hat dann auch sein System angeschlossen an diese Box, also auch ans Internet. Und der hat zum Beispiel konsequent irgendwann mal aufgehört zu lesen. Der hat nur noch, der saß nur noch da und hörte, es pollt, es läuft, es kommen jetzt Informationen rein. Also da riefen in einem bestimmten Zeitakt erst einmal täglich und dann irgendwie stündlich oder so, riefen sich die Systeme gegenseitig an und haben neue Nachrichten ausgetauscht. Und er saß dann wie vor einem offenen Kamin vor seiner 4-Gigabyte-Platte damals, das war vor zehn Jahren, das war ein Rechenzentrum. Oder noch viel mehr. Er saß davor und wärmte sich an dem Geräusch und an dem Bewusstsein, dass das System läuft. Das ist so eine Form von Konsequenz. Und ich hab dann zum Beispiel für mich versucht, auch so eine Art von, das ein bisschen zu differenzieren, so die Fähigkeit zur Ignoranz irgendwie so ein bisschen auszubauen. Ich hab mir beigebracht, ich hatte damals keinen Anrufbeantworter, zum Beispiel nicht ans Telefon zu gehen. Was nicht einfach ist, das hat mich ein oder zwei Jahre Arbeit gekostet, aber ich glaub Leute wie wir gerade und in der Zwischenzeit immer mehr Menschen, die ganz viel mit Kommunikationstechnik, ob jetzt ein Telefon, ein Handy, eine ISDN-Anlage, die, wenn man irgendwie sie richtig beherrscht, damit kann man bis zum Mond fliegen. Und Internet, ein Kilo Internet und alles mögliche. Dass man sich eine gewisse Souveränität diesen Dingen gegenüber verschafft und dazu gehört für mich einfach immer wieder jederzeit die Fähigkeit zu sagen, ich steig aus. Ich geh nicht ans Telefon. Ich lasse den Computer ausgeschaltet und geh zu meiner Tomate. Ich hatte eine Mitbewohnerin, ein altes WG-Wesen, die hatte ihr eigenes Telefon in ihrem eigenen Zimmer und ich hatte mein Telefon ohne Anrufbeantworter und hatte schon gelernt, nicht ans Telefon zu gehen, es klingelte, und sie hatte das nicht ertragen. Sie musste an mein Telefon gehen, obwohl sie gesagt hat, sie geredet das mit einigen, das könnte doch wichtig sein. Und ich will gesagt, es ist nicht wichtig, es ist nie wichtig, es ist, du glaubst immer, ein Welfruf ruft an und will mit dir ausgehen oder so, weil das ruft nur immer irgendwer an und will sich deine Stehleiter ausbohren oder hat Koma und labert dir irgendwie den Kopf zu oder irgend sowas. Es ist immer. Irgendwann hast du einfach 10.000 Mal das Telefon abgehoben. Das ist immer irgendwie sowas und du bist immer enttäuscht oder du weißt, du kannst es leisten, nicht ranzugehen. Wenn es wirklich wichtig ist, dann ruft er eine Stunde später nochmal an.
Ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich der wichtigste Lernfaktor, den wir vor uns haben in den nächsten Jahren.
Nicht ans Internet zu gehen, obwohl wir Internet haben.
Ja, egal.
Internet ist einfach nicht zu benutzen. Ich meine, wie oft hast du gehört, wenn du ein Handybesitzer bist, wie oft hast du gehört, ich hasse die Dinger. Dieses immer erreichbar sein. Ich habe gesagt, ich bin nicht immer erreichbar. Ich bin erreichbar, wenn ich es will. Es ist völlig einfach, das Ding liegen zu lassen. Man muss diesen Umgang lernen. Ich glaube, da ist auch ein riesen Handlungsbedarf. Aber den haben wir einmal scheitern sehen beim Fernsehen. Deswegen sind wir wahrscheinlich durchaus ein bisschen pessimistisch. Wenn Leute es nicht geschafft haben, ihren Kindern den Umgang mit Fernsehen beizubringen, dann stellt sich die Frage, ob es mit dem Internet geht.
Fernsehen ist nochmal was eigenes. Es kann schon sein, dass sich in Zukunft die Fähigkeit oder der Beruf des Psychologen darauf beschränkt, Leuten beizubringen, wie man Geräte wieder ausschaltet. Es gibt ja so eine technische Entwicklung. Es gibt auch nicht mehr so eine Maschine, die der Steve Jobs gebaut hat, die Next Machine. So ein eleganter schwarzer Würfel, ein toller Computer. Der hatte keinen Ausschalter mehr. Den konntest du nur noch einschalten. Du konntest ihn noch software-mäßig ausschalten. Aber um ihn hardware-mäßig auszuschalten, musstest du ihn richtig aus der Steckdose ziehen. Das fand ich schon erschreckend. Das ist irgendwie so eine... Und das geht immer weiter jetzt. Die ganzen Maschinen, Fernseher laufen Stand-by. Also es ist irgendwie immer... Es rückt immer näher. Der Tag wird kommen, wo du wirklich Geräte kaufst und die haben nur noch so eine Reißleine. Und du kannst sie einmal anwerfen, Ende. Und dann musst du mit dem Hammer ran gehen. Dann mussten sie tot schießen oder so was. Ich meine, das ist ja auch, dass die Permanent... Die Permanenz ist ja was, was bei den Medien so über uns gekommen ist. Das Radio war ja das erste Permanent-Medium, also wo 24 Stunden um die Uhr volles Programm gelaufen ist. Das Fernsehen, wer erinnert sich noch daran, dass es Fernsehsendeschluß gab? Die Jüngeren, die Älteren unter euch, werden sich noch erinnern. Es gab einmal eine Zeit, da war dann irgendwann mal im Fernsehen, und dann machte es schhhhhh und es war irgendwie so ein Schneeflöckchen am Bildschirm. Das gibt es alles.
Da haben wir mal eine schöne Sendung hier drüber gehabt, über Sachen, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Es gibt im Internet ein Testbildmuseum.
Allerdings, sehr hübsches. Es gibt eine Vereinigung inzwischen, die sich darum kümmert, dass diese Frequenzen im Radio erhalten bleiben. Also dieser Ton, der man hat, wenn man ganz nach links oder ganz nach rechts geht, der hat diese Duuuuuh, Duuuuuh. Der soll nämlich auch abgeschaltet werden. So, der Chat ist übrigens abgeschaltet, wollte ich nur sagen, weil wir gerade beim Abschalten sind. Weil wenn zu viele Leute nur noch nerven, dann wird einfach der Chat abgeschaltet, was extrem unfair ist, weil dieses alte Prinzip ist von wegen 100 Leute und 2 nerven und machen eine Sache kaputt und deswegen wird das Ganze abgeschaltet. Das ist natürlich kein faires Vorgehen, aber ich dachte, wenn wir schon beim Thema abschalten sind, dann machen wir das auch. Insofern müsst ihr euch jetzt also eigene Wege suchen, um euch miteinander zu unterhalten, ohne dass euch dabei jemand stört. Wobei wir dann wieder beim Thema Popularisierung sind. Du hast vorhin, Peter hat vorhin gesagt, dass WWW ist eigentlich der Einzug der Popkultur ins Internet.
Ja, wenn man Popkultur einfach als populäre Kultur oder als das Medium, in dem eine größtmögliche Popularisierung von irgendwas stattfinden kann, bezeichnet, dann ist es im Bezug auf das Internet wohl das WWW gewesen, das so den Durchbruch in der Öffentlichkeit geschafft hat. Um das nochmal zu sagen, das Internet ist jetzt fast 30 Jahre alt und ist bis vor wenigen Jahren, 1994, das ist vier Jahre her, man glaubt das kaum, ist das Internet in der Öffentlichkeit bekannt geworden. Im Dezember 93 hat der John Markoff in den New York Times eine Geschichte über einen Zeitungsartikel über das World Wide Web geschrieben. Das war der erste Zeitungsartikel in einer Publikumszeitschrift, sozusagen in einer Zeitung überhaupt, über das World Wide Web und dann explodierte das. Das ist vier Jahre her. Und das hat in der Zwischenzeit den Lauf der Welt verändert. Ist nicht sehr übertrieben, wenn man das so sagt. Also die VTC-Leitsträumung ins 21. Jahrhundert, die Weltwirtschaft orientiert sich daran. Also die Hoffnungen und Ahnungslosigkeiten irgendwie hängen da dran. Und das ist auch was, was Leute wie uns also so ein bisschen mit so einer Mischung aus Ratlosigkeit und Freude zurücklässt. Weil im Chrone genommen unser Traum, den wir vor zehn Jahren geträumt haben, der eigentlich relativ bescheiden war. Wir hatten mit diesen merkwürdigen Maschinen uns eingelassen und angefangen so die ersten Versuche zu machen oder Experimente, was passiert, wenn man diese Maschinen miteinander vernetzt, plötzlich so thermos und explodiert sind. Das ist einfach zu so einem Stück Weltkultur jetzt geworden. Das ist zu einem riesen Ding geworden. Das, was wir vor zehn oder 15 Jahren gemacht haben, war eine klassische Subkultur. Das war ein klassischer Underground. Das war eins von den Dingen, die in der Musik, da kommen dann irgendwann mal irgendwelche Scouts von Plattenfirmen und sagen, du kommst jetzt in die Hitparade. Pang. Und dann bist du irgendwie ein halbes Jahr lang absoluter Mainstream und dann bist du wieder weg vom Fenster und kein Mensch. Kenn dich mehr. Und was mit dem Computer Underground, mit der Computersubkultur passiert ist, ist ganz, ganz einmalig. Ich hab sowas noch nie gesehen. Das ist absolut phänomenal. Das war vor 15 Jahren als ein Stück Elektronik-Pastelei, als ein Stück exotisches Terrain, wo man irgendwie seine Neugierde so abarbeiten kann. Also Leute wie ich, die da sagen, ich mach jetzt so einen Laborversuch. Also ich setz mich vor den Computer und beobachte, ob irgendwas passiert. Und ich weiß nicht bis heute, bis zum heutigen Tage, weiß ich nicht genau, wer ist der Wissenschaftler und wer ist das Meerschweinchen. Das ist sozusagen so die offene Frage in diesem Laborversuch. Und wir alle hatten irgendwie so den bescheidenen Wunsch, dass das alles irgendwie so ein bisschen schneller, die Datenübertragung etwas schneller als mit 300 Bauts stattfindet und das ganze Zugang etwas legaler wird. Also wenn man den Versuch unternimmt, an dem großen Datennetz teilzunehmen, dass man nicht eine internationale Geheimdienst- und Polizeiaktion auslöst, wie das noch exakt vor zehn Jahren bei dieser NASA-Geschichte der Fall war. Und was ist passiert innerhalb von zehn Jahren? Heute ist es erste Bürgerpflicht. Ältere Damen werden fast mit Gewalt irgendwie ins Internet geschoben. Alle müssen jetzt, jetzt müssen alle, sogar Helmut Kohl lernt, was in der Datenautobahn ist. Und man sieht immer wieder jetzt neulich erst Herr Diebken irgendwie, wie sie, man sieht dann immer, ich habe immer das Gefühl, derjenige, der mit der Schrotflinde dann da steht und entzwingt, dass er vor dem Rechner sitzen bleibt, da wird dann immer nicht mit aufs Bild genommen, das ist dann irgendeine Aussage. Wenn man sieht, so kinksig und diese ganzen Leute werden dann so irgendwie mit so großen Rechen vor einem Computer geschoben und müssen sich dann fotografieren lassen und müssen einen Chat machen und so weiter.
Also ich sag mal so, ich will ja jetzt nichts direkt Negatives sagen, aber einer der Leute, die wir hier auch problemlos in diesem Raum hätten laden können, weil er eigentlich auch zum Urschleim gehört, einer der jetzt in, sagen wir mal, Leipzig ansässig ist, der verdient sein Geld jetzt schon einige Zeit damit, so Telekonferenzen für Politiker zu organisieren. Der nimmt da wie alle Parteien und so, ich meine jetzt nicht unbedingt rechts außen oder so, aber ich glaube, der hat jetzt gerade Termine mit den Grünen und so und das ist also, vielleicht laden wir den sogar noch mal in eine eigene Sendung ein. Also der hat auch Erheiternis da schon erlebt. Es gibt diese Männer mit den Maschinengewehren, die sozusagen die Politiker, das ist eben die PR-Abteilung, das sind diese, die siehst du da immer schon dezent im Hintergrund stehen, das sind diese mit den schwarzen Anzügen und den ausgebollten und so, die, wo du immer denkst, das ist ja Bodyguard, aber nee, das sind sozusagen die von der PR-Abteilung, der entsprechenden Partei, gebrieften Leute, die, also, weil es ist in der Tat so, das Internet hat irgendwie so einen Zukunftsdrive irgendwie eingebaut. Also alle glauben und das ist das ganz Entscheidende und das erlebt man ja auch im Wirtschaftszusammenhängen. Also diese ganzen Internetfirmen, um uns wohin auch drüber unterhalten, die jetzt an der Börse wahnsinnig hoch bewertet wurden, obwohl sie de facto einfach nur rote Zahlen schreiben. Das hat einfach damit zu tun, das Ganze funktioniert insofern, weil ganz viele Leute glauben, im Internet liegt die Zukunft. Ja, aber dieser Glaube, der ist nun mal irgendwie, der hat sich durchgesetzt und alles andere ist Illusion. Zahlen und Papier sind irgendwie Quatsch. Und wenn Leute das glauben, dann versetzt das eher Berge als irgendwelche, naja.
In 100 Jahren werden sich die Leute wahrscheinlich amüsieren wie Bolle. So wie wir uns heute irgendwie an den Kopf greifen, dass jemand daran glauben konnte, dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist. So werden die sich denken, vor 100 Jahren haben die ans Internet geglaubt.
Ich fand bei dieser Geschichte mit, ich hab's wirklich unter der Überschrift Coles Online Debüt in so einer Wochencomputer Zeitschrift gelesen und ich find dabei bemerkenswert und auch bedenklich, dass man von einem Live-Chat redet. Also dass der Noch-Kanzler sich zu einem Chat stellt irgendwo und dann aber gleichzeitig dabei steht, dass drei Stunden vorher die Fragen gesammelt werden. Wenn ich nicht richtig verstanden hab, wie der Zusammenhang zwischen einem Live-Gespräch und diesem Fragensammeln besteht, aber wahrscheinlich ist das, der Ansturm wird einfach so massiv sein, dass es nicht anders zu regeln ist.
Da muss man bei Einstein nachgucken, ne?
Ich seh aber noch einen anderen Punkt. Also man wird vielleicht in 100 Jahren über das, was man jetzt als Netz kennt, lachen, aber vielleicht nur genauso wie meinetwegen übers Korbeltelefon. Die größte Maschine vorm Internet war nun mal einfach das Telefonnetz und das Telefon ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit. Es gab schon in den 30er Jahren irgendeinen, naja, damals hieß das glaube ich nicht Science Fiction, aber so ein Zukunftsroman, wo geschildert wird, dass ein Mann in die, in seinen Mantel greift, einen Telefonhörer rausholt und telefoniert. Und damals hat sich das keiner vorstellen können, aber in der Geschichte wurde das eben beschrieben und heute ist es selbstverständlich. Und die nächste Selbstverständlichkeit ist der allgegenwärtige Netzzugang. Also so auf den 1. Klasse Flughäfen, meinetwegen in London oder so, da stehen die Kisten schon rum und die Geschäftsreisenden benutzen das und einige benutzen das sogar, um meinetwegen einen Vortrag von einer Konferenz dort noch mal zu aktualisieren und sich vorhin auszudrucken.
Also was ich jetzt gerade spannend fand, war sozusagen deine kurze Erwähnung von in der Literatur dargestellten Technologien der Zukunft. Da würde ich jetzt gerne einfach mal an die Runde fragen, was für Filme oder was für Visionen euch da noch so kleben geblieben sind, die noch nicht verwirklicht sind. Also was mich mal beeindruckt hat, war eigentlich ein relativ schlechter Film, ansonsten mit David Bowie, der hieß der Mann, der vom Himmel fiel. Und es ist so ein Außerirdischer, der irgendwie herkommt und der erstmal gar nicht weiß, was hier auf dem Planet abgeht. Aber eine Szene, die fand ich beeindruckend bis heute eigentlich, der hat sich dann so 20, 30 Fernseh organisiert, da hat sich die so übereinander aufgeschabelt, dann eine riesige Wand voll Fernseh, hat für jedes Fernsehprogramm ein Fernseh gehabt und die alle gleichzeitig sozusagen laufen gehabt. Da hat sich da vorgesetzt und irgendwie nur den trockenen Satz gesagt, ich will Information. Und das fand ich irgendwie beeindruckend im Sinne von, dass man am Netz ja dieses Gefühl der Teilhabe hat, man ist irgendwie ein Teil eines Kommunikationszusammens oder wie du vorhin sagtest, man vergrößert ein bisschen sein Gehirn, aber auch so die Frage nach der Aufnahmefähigkeit. Also so ein bisschen kenne ich das von mir auch so, also irgendwie so 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 und mittlerweile dann doch, im Viertelstundentakt will man dann mal seine Mail kurz lesen und gucken, ob was Frisches reingekommen ist. Also so ein bisschen kenne ich zumindest dieses Suchtverhalten von mir, seit ich eine Standleitung habe oder wie auch immer, dass man dann mal zwischendurch sich mal so einen Status verschafft.
Ich finde diese Frage sehr, sehr interessant. Mit der habe ich mich auch schon sehr intensiv beschäftigt. Und zwar die Frage, ob wir, unsere ganze Kultur ist seit, und zwar die ganze menschliche Kultur, eigentlich geprägt von der Schriftkultur. Seit 5 oder 6.000 Jahren wollen wir großzügig sein. Und diese Schriftkultur hat uns festgelegt auf so eine Linearität im Denken. Das heißt, alles, was in unserem Bewusstsein oder so in dem Teil, den wir die Vernunft bezeichnen, sich abspielt, es baut auf auf diesen Zeilenfaden, auf dieser Linearität. Das heißt, da geht was von A nach B. Das siehst du in der Mathematik, in der Logik, überall. Und es ist ein ganz, ganz massives Grundmuster in unserem Denken, in unserer ganzen Kultur. Und jetzt mit so Konzepten wie diesem Hypertextkonzept, dem, was da im World Wide Web passiert, sehen wir, es bricht auf, es geht in so eine Vielheit. Das heißt, du hast immer so eine Gleichzeitigkeit, so Möglichkeiten, wo du abzweigen kannst und so weiter. So Sachen, die es bisher, die dich im Grunde genommen dazu zwingen oder verlocken, die das unheimlich attraktiv erscheinen lassen, 30 Fernseher vor sich aufzubauen und zu sagen, okay, wie viel kriege ich in mich rein? Kann ich 30 Programme gleichzeitig gucken? Und jetzt muss man sagen, es gibt Menschen, die in der Lage sind, mit hohen Graden an Gleichzeitigkeiten zu operieren. Und zwar nennt man die Komponisten. Also wenn ich jetzt Beethoven bin und eine Symphonie komponiere, dann muss ich, ich weiß nicht wie viele Stimmen, sondern wie viele Instrumente ein großes Orchester hat. Ich sage jetzt mal Hausnummer 200. Oder 100 ist auch schon eine Ecke. Und wenn du Komponist bist, musst du diese 100 Instrumente gleichzeitig in deinem Kopf hören können, sonst kannst du keine Symphonie schreiben. Das heißt, das kann ein Mensch. Ein Mensch kann 100 Instrumente gleichzeitig denken. Sonst könnte ein Mensch keine Symphonien schreiben. Aber es gibt noch keine Menschen, oder das könnte man mit einem großen Fragezeichen versehen, die sowas sozusagen auf der vernünftigen oder auf der sprachlichen Ebene stattfinden lassen können, oder auf der Ebene von 30 oder 200 Fernsehprogrammen. Und vielleicht ist das jetzt eine Frage, die wir uns stellen sollten, ob sich unsere Kultur verändert. Ob wir momentan jetzt an der Schwelle stehen, wo wir sagen, es gibt so Symptome, es gibt Zeichen, äußere zu denen gehört das Internet, dass diese Linearität aufbricht. Es gibt im 20. Jahrhundert in unserer Zeit eine Kunstrichtung, so in den 20er- 30er-Jahren die Tacubismus. Das waren Künstler, die meiner Meinung nach sehr tief vorausgeahnt haben, was so zu Ende des Jahrhunderts und des Jahrtausends irgendwie auf uns zukommt. Und zwar die Bilder, der berühmtest ist Picasso. Wie Picasso gemalt hat, das waren Gesichter, wo du sozusagen ein Gesicht von mehreren Richtungen gleichzeitig gesehen hast. Das war nicht die klassische perspektivische oder fotografische Information, das siehst du ein Gesicht aus einer Richtung. Sondern der Cubismus hat gezeigt, ein Gesicht gleichzeitig im Profil und das Augenpaar von vorne. Das heißt, das war schon mal so ein Versuch, so dieses Informationsproblem, mit dem wir jetzt zu tun haben, irgendwie zu lösen. In dem du sagst, pass auf, wir kommen mit dieser klassischen Betrachtungsweise, kommen wir nicht mehr weiter. Oder ein anderes Beispiel, der Schiedsrichter bei einem Fußballspiel ist im Grunde genommen ein Vertreter der alten Zeit. Der muss mit seinen popeligen zwei Augen und seinem subjektiven Standpunkt auf dem Spielfeld entscheiden, ob jetzt irgendwie, das war das jetzt Upside oder nicht. Und jeder Fernsehzugucker, der irgendwie, jeder Couchpotato, der im Unterhemd auf dem Sofa rumhängt, kriegt mindestens fünf Kameraperspektiven plus Zeitlupe eingespielt und hat eine wesentlich bessere Entscheidungsgrundlage als der Schiedsrichter. Also das sind so Sachen, das könnte man jetzt sagen, das sind so Symptome oder Zeichen, die vielleicht darauf hinweisen, dass wir uns die Frage stellen, sondern es gibt in der Hardware-Technik eine Entwicklung, die heißt Parallelrechner. Das heißt, da wird nicht mehr einfach ein Prozessor, so wie es bisher ist, in einem Computer eingebaut, sondern teilweise bis zu 240.000. Also Connection-Maschinen, das sind so riesen Parallelrechner. Und ich hab mich gefragt, was sind das für Leute, die so eine Maschine, in der 200.000 Prozessoren gleichzeitig arbeiten? Nicht hintereinander, so wie es bisher immer stattgefunden hat. Was sind das für Leute? Wie muss man denken, um so eine Maschine programmieren zu können? Vielleicht sind das die Pioniere oder Leute, die so komplexe Hypertextgebilde versuchen, zu programmieren, zu steuern, also absichtsvoll irgendwie zu gestalten. Und ich glaub, falls da irgendwas in unserem Gehirn wieder passieren sollte, bin ich sicher, dass das nicht irgendwie eine Frage von 10 Jahren oder von 100 Jahren ist, sondern das ist eine Frage, also das ist eher was, was sozusagen in so ein bisschen biologischen Zeiträumen möglicherweise stattfindet, aber es ist einfach trotzdem wert, sich diese Frage zu stellen. Vielleicht werden wir sozusagen keine Antwort oder keine Gewissheit drüber kriegen, aber ich finde, es gibt eine Menge Symptome, die darauf hinweisen, dass in unserer Kultur oder mit dem Menschen wieder irgendwas vor sich geht. Und vielleicht passiert in uns was, das ist das eigentlich Wesentliche. Vielleicht ist das, was wir außen sehen, die ganze Technik, die ganze gigantische technologische Umwelt, die gerade stattfindet, eigentlich nur ein Schatten, die irgendwas wirft, was in uns schon lange im Gange ist. Also irgendwas, wo wir plötzlich erkennen können, dass irgendwas in uns passiert.
Ja.
Wir hören Chaos Radio, so wie jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, hier bei Fritz. Das heißt der Chaos Computer Club ist hier und beschäftigt sich mit Themen, die er oder sie, je nachdem was für eine schlechte Chaos Computer Club hat, für interessant hält. Heute ist das so ein kleiner Rückblick eigentlich. Sind so die Chaos Computer Club Rentner hier. Rentner ist ein fieser Austausch, finde ich. Andi ist hier, Vau ist hier, Vic ist da und Peter Glaz ist da.
Ich bin auch wirklich noch ein bisschen vom Rentner, Alter.
Frührentner, Frührentner, das war vorpensioniert, so zu sagen, Andi. Wir haben absichtlich die Musik dann hochgezogen, weil wir haben gedacht, darüber lassen wir euch jetzt erstmal eine Weile nachdenken, was das Peter gerade gesagt hat. Aber dieser Begriff Komponist ist natürlich sehr interessant, weil der Gedanke, den Gang, den du hattest, dass du gesagt hast, es ist also möglich, diese ganzen verschiedenen Instrumente oder diese verschiedenen Informationen zu verarbeiten. Es gibt Menschen, die das können. Die Frage ist, ob das nicht vielleicht umgekehrt ist, denn Komponisten ordnen diese verschiedenen Informationen ja, so damit andere fähig werden, sie in einem Zusammenhang zu hören und eigentlich nur noch als eins zu empfinden. Und da wir jetzt langsam aber sicher mal so ein bisschen auf Zukunftsvision gehen sollten und Zukunftsausblicke, irgendwie die Frage, wo sind denn die Komponisten, die diese ganzen Informationen, die jetzt auf uns einprasseln und für uns eigentlich unhörbar sind, größtenteils, weil es zu viel wird, wie kann man die Bündel zu einem zusammenfassen, was dann für alle verständlich wird und auch Sinn macht?
Also ich denke, die Komponisten, die entstehen dezentral und überall, einfach dadurch, dass, also für mich ist Realität, falls es sowas überhaupt gibt oder Wahrheit oder was auch immer, dass objektive und wie Gesamte sein soll, die Gesamtheit aller sozusagen virtuellen Realitäten. Also Wahrheit ist die Gesamtheit aller Lügen und Realität ist die Gesamtheit aller persönlichen virtuellen Realitäten. Und wenn ich dem Konzept sozusagen folge, dann heißt das, je mehr ich von einzelnen Wahrnehmungshorizonten aus das Ganze zu betrachten lerne oder je mehr Darstellungen ein und derselben Sache ich irgendwie mir reinziehen kann, desto mehr bin ich auch in der Lage, ein Bild zu fassen, was diese einzelnen Wahrnehmungen beinhaltet. Und damit sozusagen bin ich ja Komponist. Also ich meine, das Komponieren, das macht sicherlich jeder erstmal selbst für sich. Und der Komponist, wie wir ihn jetzt sozusagen, wir haben ja jetzt auch über den Konzert irgendwie Komponisten geredet oder was auch immer, das ist ja jetzt eine direkte Tätigkeit, wo sich einer hinstellt und dann irgendwie sich was ausdenkt und dann irgendwie die Leute dirigiert. Aber ich denke, erstmal ist jeder heutzutage, und das ist ja auch ein bisschen das, was es an gesellschaftlicher Realität schon verändert hat und immer mehr verändert, es gibt nicht mehr die gesellschaftliche Realität. Es gibt eine dermaßen Anzahl gesellschaftlicher Realitäten und Komponisten in diesen gesellschaftlichen Realitäten. Also ich glaube, die Entwicklung hat schon längst begonnen und das ist keine Frage mehr, sondern es ist nur noch eine Frage, ob man es wahrnimmt oder ob man den Fernseher anschaltet und RTL kauft.
Das ist so ein bisschen abstrakt. Also ich glaube, das, was Johnny sagt, geht auch in so eine Richtung. Die Frage, du hast in den klassischen Medien, in den Zeitungen, im Fernsehen, auch im Radio eine Struktur, wo es Leute gibt, die dafür ausgebildet sind, Informationen vorzusortieren, zu redigieren. Du hast eine Redaktion. Und das ist zum Beispiel was, was du im Netz nicht hast oder fast nicht hast. Jetzt kann man sagen, für viele Leute ist das Netz zum Beispiel so eine Art kreative Zumutung, also eine Überforderung. Das heißt, du kriegst die ganzen Teile, die du zum Beispiel in einer Zeitung nach wirklich sehr anspruchsvollen Kriterien oder nach journalistischen Kriterien, die zum Teil einen sehr hohen Maßstab folgen, vorsortiert, ausgewählt, gestaltet, da arbeiten verschiedene, gut ausgebildete Berufsgruppen, Layouter, Typografen, Setser, Hersteller und so weiter zusammen, dir so ein Produkt zu liefern, das sowohl dein Auge befriedigt, dein Unterhaltungsbedürfnis, als auch dein Informationsbedürfnis in so einer Kombination, die sich in langen Jahren oder Jahrhunderten so als praktikabel herausgestellt hat. Und jetzt kommt das Internet und jetzt kommt Multimedia und sie reißen alles auseinander in Stücke und sagen, hey, und hier hast du die Audiofiles und da hast du 10.000 GIFs und da hast du ein paar Bildchen und da hast du irgendwie Massen an Informationen und Texten und alles roh und so. Und klar, du kannst dir deine individuelle Zeitung jetzt machen. Und dann stehst du da und sagst, aber irgendwie, ja, aber ich hab ja gar keine Zeit. Also ich kann, das ist so wie wenn du versuchst, wenn du einen 8-Stunden-Job hast und makrobiotisch essen willst, wo du irgendwie drei Stunden brauchst, um dein Essen zuzubereiten. Das geht irgendwie, es wäre vielleicht viel gesünder.
Na ja, aber es tut doch jeder, Peter. Ich meine, jeder von uns und jeder da draußen stellt sich doch seine Realität anhand der bestimmten Quantitäten an Information. Ich meine, jeder gibt sich, wir haben vorhin diesen Satz, den ich eigentlich unterschreiben möchte, also die Mische macht so. Und jeder stellt doch heute selbst für sich fest, wie viel Mail und wie viel News und wie viel Web und wie viel Fernsehen und wie viel Zeitung er will oder wie viele Tomatenpflanzen.
Aber wir haben hart daran gearbeitet, ne?
Aber was ist da dran visionier? Ich meine, ihr stellt euch jetzt irgendwie, ihr setzt euch hier hin und diskutiert, wer wie das Web benutzt. Also ich denke mal, ich möchte mich eigentlich mal jetzt geistig ein bisschen von der Erde abheben und das Ganze mal aus dem Weltall betrachten.
Kannst du das behalten? Klar. Schaffst du das gleich noch?
Das schaff ich.
Das ist voll doof, jemand so aus dem Fluss rauszunehmen, aber ich hoffe du schaffst es gleich noch. Ein extrem großes Team von Layoutern, Redakteuren, Journalisten und Schriftsetzern hat jetzt für euch vorbereitet folgendes.
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
Möller 31, nämlich Zeit für das Einlenken. Die libysche Führung hat angedeutet, dass sie die beiden mutmaßlichen Lockerbie Attentäter eventuell ausliefert. Die USA und Großbritannien haben vorgeschlagen, dass ihnen in den Niederlanden der Prozess gemacht wird. Bei dem Anschlag auf eine US Passagiermaschine waren im Dezember 88 Uhr dem schottischen Lockerbie 270 Menschen getötet worden. Krisentreffen vor dem Hintergrund des Rubelverfalls ist der amtierende russische Ministerpräsident Gennomyrdin mit dem Chef des internationalen Währungsfonds Cam D'Aixu zusammengekommen. Beide trafen sich am Abend auf der Schwarzmeer Halbinsel Krim. Im Tagesverlauf hatte der Rubel weiter dramatisch an Wert verloren. Ermittlungen, das Eisenbahnbundesamt hat Staatsanwaltschaften in ganz Deutschland gebeten, dem Verdacht von Verstößen gegen das Strafgesetzbuch und gegen das Atomgesetz durch Unternehmen nachzugehen. Laut Berliner Zeitung geht es um Firmen, die in den Skandal um radioaktiv verseuchte Atommülltransporte verwickelt sind. Unwetter, der Hurricane Bonnie hat die Ostküste der USA erreicht. Die Sturmfront hat eine Breite von 640 Kilometern. Für North- und South Carolina sowie Virginia ist der Notstand ausgerufen worden. Etwa eine halbe Million Menschen haben sich ins Landesinnere in Sicherheit gebracht. Fußball Bayern München hat die Hauptrunde der Champions League erreicht. In der Qualifikation schafften die Bayern nach dem 4-0-Hinspielsieg im Rückspiel bei Obelitz-Bellgrad ein 1 zu 1 unentschieden.
Wette.
Heute Nacht einzelne Schauer 10 bis 7 Grad, tagsüber wechselhaft Temperaturen bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr.
A13 von Dresden in Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Schwarzheide und Klettwitz ist die A13 nach einem Verkehrsunfall voll gesperrt. In Richtung Berlin bitte die U25 nutzen und in Richtung Dresden die U14.
Ein Fritz-Kurz-Info mit Gerald Kötterheimers.
Fritz präsentiert eine Fritzparty in Schwarzheide mit DJ Sammy und Luna. Luna und DJ Sammy unterstützt von den Fritz-DJs Stefan Michme und Frank Manzel. Freitag, 28. August in der Wandelhof-Diskothek Schwarzheide. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Vick, ich hab dich ganz fies unterbrochen.
Also, wo waren wir stehen geblieben? Ich wollte das nicht so sehr aus meiner eigenen Perspektive, sondern einfach mal aus der Vogelperspektive betrachten, das Ganze. Und was mir dann auffällt, ist, dass die Welt, aus dem sozusagen, ich betrachte jetzt mal nur die Erde, aus der Entfernung gesehen, jetzt zu einem Organismus eigentlich zusammenwächst mit den Netzen als Nerven. Das heißt, die neue Qualität, die durch diese weltumspannenden Netze entsteht, ist, dass es im Prinzip ein ganzheitlich funktionierender und pulsierender Körper wird, diese Welt. Das, glaube ich, ist eine entscheidende Qualität, die sich auch weiterhin fortsetzen wird.
Ein Eindruck ist, dass das Internet gegenwärtig die Intelligenz einer Quale hat. Also ich schreibe an dem Punkt Qualität mit 2L und das Ding wächst und wächst vor sich hin und man kann es nicht mehr abschalten. Man kann es vielleicht versuchen an die Wand zu nageln, aber es lebt und es wächst weiter.
Und wie so oft gibt es zwei Leitungen, die hier schon eine ganze Weile geschaltet sind. Das heißt, ich hab hier so eine Reihe von Knöpfen und ich kann die Leute schon auf Sendung nehmen sozusagen, aber ihr Regler, ihr Mikrofon ist noch leise und wenn die dann so da 20 Minuten liegen, dann frage ich mich immer, ob die noch dran sind. Und das kann man dann hier hören, dass wir zum Beispiel nicht mehr dran sind. Hat hier jemand durchgehalten? Hallo?
Ich meine dich, hallo.
Ja, der war, endlich. Ich dachte schon, ich müsste jetzt gänzlich eure Sendung bis zum Schluss über das Telefon hören. Klingt nicht so toll wie über das Radio ansonsten. Meine Frage an die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club ist, also ihr habt jetzt schon relativ viel über bestimmte Sachen in Richtung Komponieren und über Künstler erreichen können, übers Netz gesprochen. Ihr habt aber noch nicht darüber gesprochen, dass zum Beispiel die Hacker auch eine eigene Musikkultur haben und wie die zu erreichen ist. Und wie die dann klingt, da habt ihr glaube ich in euren Sendungen auch bisher wenig zugemacht. Und da würde ich einfach mal die Frage an die Runde stellen, warum und wie denn diese Erzeugnisse klingen und so weiter.
Also wir haben glaube ich zu dem Thema, wir haben eine Sendung gehabt mit MPEG 3s, wir haben eine Sendung gehabt mit Mods. Wir haben da schon eine ganze Menge drüber gemacht. Und das ist natürlich jetzt ein sehr spezieller Bereich, also zu sagen, dass die Hacker-Kultur auch eine eigene Musikkultur entwickelt hat. Das ist unbestritten, aber ich glaube wir sind allgemeiner im Moment.
Ja, das ist sicherlich richtig. Es war nur eine Frage an die etwas älteren Herren, die Rentner sozusagen, ob da noch mal ein bisschen was nachzuliegt ist, wie das klingen kann. Allerdings muss ich dann einfach sagen, dass ich die Sendung nicht gehört habe.
Also sagen wir es mal so, irgendwann werde ich noch mal stinkend reich. Ein Freund von mir hat mal eine Kassette aufgenommen, wo er nur die ganzen alten C64-Lieder, also der C64 war der verbreitete Homecomputer, da gab es so einige Tonmusikprogramme eben schon einige Zeit bevor es so seriöse Media-Applikationen und ähnliches gab. Ja genau, der hat nur so Zusammenstellungen von so alten C64-Liedern irgendwie. Und damit könnte ich die Altherrenrunde hier jetzt im Raum auf sicher erfreuen. Ich habe sie leider jetzt gerade nicht im Auto liegen, die Kassette. Aber ansonsten würde ich das fast ein bisschen bestreiten, dass die Hacker-Kultur eine eigene Musikrichtung hervorgebracht hat. Weil ich glaube, da unterscheiden sich unsere persönlichen Geschmäcker doch irgendwie relativ zu gravierend. Also ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, auf was du da hinauswirst. Klar, es ist irgendwie auch Musikinstrumente sind irgendwie verfügbar und auch die Synthikultur und das Netz hat da irgendwie einen Austausch. Aber das ist eher dieses mp3 Thema und das weiß ich nicht. Das ist jetzt eigentlich nicht so ganz.
Ich glaube, gemeinsame kulturelle Interessen gibt es eher bei der Literatur oder in einem bestimmten Bereich von Literatur, nämlich Science Fiction. Also es ist relativ, es ist relativ überdurchschnittlich ein Interesse an Science Fiction bei Leuten, die mit Computer und dem Internet oder jetzt auch speziell bei Hackern irgendwie zu tun haben, zu beobachten.
Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt irgendwann mal jemand, der auftritt und sagt, der Computer ist kein Zukunftsinstrument, sondern ein Vergangenheitsinstrument. Das würde erklären, dass wir jetzt noch nicht...
Ach man, dafür musstest du jetzt lange warten, Noah.
Naja, das ist eine Pech bei der Sache, er hat...
Das können wir nicht mal ein Lied für ihn singen, weil wir keine Musikkultur haben.
Na ja, aber ich hab ja ein bisschen Musikkultur mitgebracht.
Ja genau, das was im Hintergrund läuft ist ja durchaus, vielleicht nicht unbedingt jetzt ein reines Produkt des Netzes, sicher nicht, aber auf alle Fälle natürlich ein eindeutiges Produkt.
Also die Verfügbarkeit der Produktionsmittel ist ja nicht nur im Bereich des Textes und des Gehirnschmalzes, sondern auch im Bereich der Musik durchaus irgendwie...
Offensichtlich.
Uwe, bist du selber Musiker? Musikwissenschaftler? Insofern nehme ich an, dass das dann wahrscheinlich deine Diplomarbeit irgendwie... Nein.
Das ist nicht meine Diplomarbeit, das ist nur Semesterarbeit.
Aber du beschäftigst dich extrem damit?
Nein, extrem würdest du das nicht nennen, aber halt im Rahmen einer Semesterarbeit halt damit.
Und kommst du denn im Rahmen dieser Arbeit zu dem Schluss, dass es so was gibt, wie eine Internet... Aus dem Internet entstandene Musikkultur?
Man muss uns das sagen, wir müssen das wissen.
Na ja, aus dem Internet entstanden vielleicht nicht. Also die Musik denke ich mir gerade bei den Mods findet man halt schon, dass sie gewisse signifikante Qualitätsmerkmale dessen trägt, was das Internet beziehungsweise, was vor allem auch Computer und den Umgang mit Computer und der Veräußerung über Computer zu tun hat. Also das kann man dann schon in der Musik wiederfinden.
Und und zwar, wie spiegelt sich das wieder?
Na ja, gerade in den Mods kann man das sehr schön ablesen, an der quasi Verlinkung der Samples, in dem auch teilweise die Namen angegeben werden, wo man das wiederfinde, das ist ja nichts anderes im Grunde genommen als eine Hypertext Struktur. Ja, könnte man so sagen. Er hat es ja mit dem Komponieren an sich auch schon angesprochen, wobei ich ihm dann doch mal einen Blick in alte Autografen empfehlen würde, wo man dann immer wieder findet, dass die Leute doch etwas linearer gedacht haben oder denken, als man immer so annimmt. Dann schlicht und ergreifend die technischen Möglichkeiten, die der Computer Bill zur Verfügung stellt, die dann auch zu solchen Strukturen führen, also das Kopieren zum Beispiel von bestimmten Bereichen. Das gab es zwar in der Vergangenheit auch schon mit den Faulenzern, aber die werden hier natürlich viel massiver noch benutzt als vorher. Und im Techno findet man das ja auch schon. Also da vorzugsweise natürlich über die Midifizierung und dann halt entsprechende externen Geräte. Aber insofern sind die Mods natürlich ein sehr spezielles Thema, da sie natürlich genau wie die alte C64 Musik die Möglichkeiten des Computers, nur die Möglichkeiten des Computers genutzt haben. Und natürlich auch die Möglichkeit der Distribution. Und natürlich auch ganz viel von dem, dass ganz viel der Hacker-Kultur halt auch frei zugänglich ist und auch kein Geld kostet. Was üblicherweise ja gerade bei Musik oftmals nicht der Fall ist.
Was sind denn deine Gedankengänge, wenn du dich so damit beschäftigst und so da rangehst und sagst, die Distribuierung von Musik ist natürlich und die Kopierbarkeit der digitalen Daten irgendwie. Dieses Stichwort Audio on Demand, das ist ja in aller Munde, Music on Demand, abrufen, die Telekom investiert, eine Menge Geld, andere Leute auch, auch da wieder neu Goldgräberstimmung. Was sind deine Gedanken dazu zu dem Thema?
Schwierig, da bin ich noch nicht fertig mit den Gedanken. Da möchte ich jetzt noch nichts zu sagen. Ich denke mir, die Programmgestaltung dürfte nicht so ganz einfach sein, wie sie sich das alle vorstellen. Und auch die Leute, die das betreiben, haben, glaube ich, noch eine etwas falsche Vorstellung davon. Also da meine ich jetzt nicht speziell die Telekom mit, da die ja nur einen Dienst zur Verfügung stellen. Und das Programm von den anderen Leuten, den Vertrieben, den Alten, beziehungsweise also von den Künstlern, wer zusammengestellt wird. Wobei natürlich da auch noch andere Anbieter auf dem Markt erscheinen werden, die da auch ganz andere Ziele mitverfolgen werden und die ihr Programm mit Sicherheit auch anders gestalten werden.
Das sehe ich ja auch.
Es gibt, kann ich in dem Zusammenhang sagen, am kommenden Samstag in 100 Grad, wofür ich Werbung machen darf, weil das auch ein ORB-Teil ist hier, die beschäftigen sich ganz ausführlich mit diesem Thema. Jo, Uwe, dank dir. Ach, da könnte man jetzt noch mal drei Stunden ranhängen. Also jetzt im Moment könnten wir nicht noch mal drei Stunden ranhängen, glaube ich, aber man könnte sie ja in einem Monat ranhängen zum Thema, welche unterschiedlichen Kulturbereiche der Kulturbereiche, um den wir uns jetzt die ganze Zeit gekümmert haben, noch beeinflusst hat. Von Musik über Literatur über Theater nicht unbedingt. Gibt es ein Theaterstück was?
Es gab mal eine Ballettaufführung, wo irgendwie Tänzer mit einem Roboterarm zusammen aufgetreten sind. Klingt schlimm.
VRML ist eben noch nicht so weit.
Ich meine es gab Fighting Machines, die diese künstlichen Roboter zusammengeschraubt haben, die dann gegen die Gegner waren.
Stimmt und es gibt natürlich die Fußball-WM der Roboter und es gibt Performance Art.
Aber vielleicht lernen wir jetzt über das Benutzen dieser Netze eine Frage, die die Menschheit schon seit Jahrhunderten beschäftigt. Nämlich wie funktioniert unser Gehirn? Ich glaube, dieser Frage haben wir schon lange versucht, logisch näher zu kommen. Auf dem Weg schaffen wir es vielleicht nicht, aber vielleicht schaffen wir es auf dem Weg, dass wir die Erde als ganzes Gehirn betrachten, als einen ebenso komplexen Nervenorganismus und dadurch sozusagen unter Umständen wieder einen Brocken dazu geliefert bekommen, wie eigentlich unser Bewusstsein funktioniert.
Es gibt bereits bestimmte Ansätze dazu. Man hat sich gefragt, wie eine Wüstenameise es schafft, sich zu orientieren mit vielleicht nur 100.000 Neuronen. Also angesichts von paar Millionen Transistorfunktionen in der CPU. Heute sind 100.000 Neuronen einfach ein Klacks. Das müsste man emulieren können. Und damit ist das Viech in der Lage, durch die Wüste zu zu rennen, sich zu orientieren, eine Beute zu finden, die Beinchen zu koordinieren und auf dem Rückweg nicht irgendwie zigzag, sondern schnurstracks zur eigenen Höhle zurückzufinden. Und da hat die Wissenschaft ziemlich lange dran rumgeknuspert, bis er halt rausgekriegt hat, dass die ganz Verarbeitungsstrukturen ineinander verkettet sind. Und das sind Programmiermethoden, die bei den heutigen Betriebssystemen noch überhaupt nicht angedacht sind.
Wer ist jetzt aber nicht von Spaghetti-Code?
Schlimmer. Und ich meine so als Kern, wir leben heute erst im Binärzeitalter, noch nicht im Digitalzeitalter. Im Binärzeitalter gibt es nur 0 und 1. Und wenn man überlegt, was er empfindet, wenn er Zahnschmerzen hat, da gibt es zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Zum einen, wie weh es tut und zum anderen, in welchem Takt das pulst, der Schmerz. Und das einzige technische, wirklich digitale und nicht binäre System ist das Morse-System. Und wenn ich Informatiker ärgern will, dann frage ich die, was denn die Information der Handschrift beim Morsen ist. Wofür man, meinetwegen zur Nazi-Zeit einen erschossen hat. Das sind ja nicht die Zeichen, die übertragen werden, sondern der Rhythmus. Das hat auch was mit, na ja, also ich habe jetzt in Kiel Jazz von einer Polizeikombo gehört und Freund sagte, das klingt genauso wie wenn eine Militärkapelle klassische Musik spielt. Und das ist eine Handschrift. Die ist eine Information, die nicht leicht zu fassen ist. Und das denke ich ist der Übergang zum Digitalzeitalter, vom Binärzeitalter, was wir jetzt haben.
Na ja, aber da geritzt auch wieder in Bereiche. Also mir fallen da spontan neuronale Netze ein. Beispielsweise das, was irgendwie Gesellschaft für Zahlungssysteme mit der EuroCard macht. Irgendwie da wird eben, da lernt das System das Verhalten des Kreditkarten- Benutzers kennen und wenn dann eine Transaktion kommt, die also diesem gelernten Profil eben abweichendes, dann wird das als zumindest potenzieller Missbrauch erkannt.
Die sind an der Spitze der Entwicklung durchaus.
Meine neuronale Netzwerke, okay, vielleicht, das ist zumindest ein Forschungswerk, auch wo noch einiges passiert. Das sind eben dezentrale, kleine, vernetzte Systeme, die wir lernt.
Aber was man begreifen muss, ist, dass das Internet selbst ein neuronales Netzwerk ist.
Ja, und dass das Gehirn das auch ist.
Ja, eben, deswegen sage ich ja, davon lernen wir vielleicht das letzte fehlende Stück auf dem Weg zum Bewusstsein.
Na ja, gut, ich meine, andere Leute meinen, das schon längst gefunden zu haben und nennen es Berlin ist Gott. Also ich meine, ich kenne durchaus Vertreter dieser Fraktion, die sagen, das was ihr da sucht, das haben wir schon längst und das haben sie vor 2000 Jahren mal irgendwie an den Baum genagelt und so weiter und so fort. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht religiös werden, wie in der letzten 15 Stunden, aber das ist auch nicht wirklich meine Art.
Dieses Verfahren ist aber nicht kopierbar und die Computer machen Informationen kopierbar.
Hast du das Verfahren mit dem Baum?
Nein, das Wissen, den Zugang zum Wissen.
Ich finde schon, dass das was wegsagt hat, was für sich, dass das Internet eine große gehirnartige Struktur ist. Es gibt auch viele Dinge, so wie vorhin bei dem Telefonanrufer, der über Dinge, die er im Internet findet, erschreckt oder über die Qualität oder eben das, was er als Nichtqualität empfindet. Das heißt, wir sehen auch Teile des Unterbewusstseins oder von so einem kollektiven Unterbewusstsein ausgebreitet, Sachen, die eben erschreckend sind, Sachen, die aber trotzdem in uns, in den Menschen drin sind, ob es uns jetzt gefällt oder nicht. Man muss doch nicht gleich werten. Man muss sich sozusagen, man kann sich mal so einer etwas ganzheitlicheren Realität annähern. Und ich glaube, es gibt kaum einen stärkeren Antrieb für uns, irgendwas zu tun, als irgendwas über uns selber herauszufinden, diese Nullkette herauszukriegen, wer wir sind und was es mit uns auf sich hat, wie wir funktionieren. Und das hat so ein bisschen reduziert, technisch zu begreifen. Und es hat auch, es ist so eine narzisstische Lust. Du suchst immer einen Spiegel, in dem du versuchst dich irgendwie wiederzufinden oder vielleicht sogar auf so eine erhöhte Art und Weise wiederzufinden. Und dann hast du da irgendwie das Internet. Und was Vick hier vorhin auch beschrieben hat, so dieses Gefühl, ich kann jetzt um den ganzen Planeten rumfassen. Ich kann irgendwie dieses Allmachtgefühl, das ist auch, jeder von uns hat das irgendwann mal erlebt, als man zum ersten Mal irgendwie mit einem Computer zu tun hatte. Oh, ich kann in Sydney in ein Sack Reis umschmeißen, indem ich einfach hier tipptipptipp mache oder sowas. Oder jetzt, also auch, das ist jetzt ein bisschen ironisch formuliert. So einfach dieses Gefühl, so wie Efeu irgendwie, um die ganze Erde rum zu ranken oder mit so einer anderen Qualität. Ich kann auch jemanden in Sydney anrufen und irgendwie, aber das ist eine vollkommen andere Qualität. Im Netz hat es so eine gewisse Selbstverständlichkeit und so eine gewisse, also das Netz hat auch auf der einen Seite dieses, du hast das Gefühl, deine Haut explodiert, du bist plötzlich so groß wie der ganze Planet und auf der anderen Seite siehst du doch so eine Art Spiegel, also du suchst dich irgendwie selber drin. Ich will mal ein Beispiel sagen, ich habe irgendwann mal mich, wie auch jeder von uns, mit Datenbanken beschäftigt. Dann habe ich mir mal angeguckt, also es ist ja so, Vau hat früher mal von Uhrmachern gesprochen, als so ein Teil dieser ganzen technischen Entwicklung, die so die Kultur genommen hat. Und es ist so, dass die, so jetzt habe ich einen Faden verloren, durch diese wunderschöne traumverlorene Musik. Ich finde ihn aber gleich wieder. Also warte mal, da war der Spiegel.
Vau hat von Uhrmachern geredet.
Ja, warte mal.
Der Blickser Bargert sagte dazu, ich bin das gesamte chinesische Volk.
Was uns jetzt nicht wirklich weiterhilft, aber es ist hier etwas unter Einbruch.
Das ist auch eine Formulierung von diesem Allmachtgefühl, glaube ich.
Na ja, okay, aber das trifft auch schon wieder zu arg ins Individuelle ab. Denn was ich eigentlich meinte, das kann ich wieder an so einem Beispiel erläutern, dass dieser Organismus eben auch auf Defekte so ähnlich reagiert wie unser Gehirn. Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt jemanden mal ordentlich auf den Kopf gehauen hat, also eine Lesion des Gehirns stattgefunden hat, dann sind einige Funktionen erstmal weg, weil einige Netzknoten kaputt sind. So. Und ebenso ist es auch mit Internet. Wenn man jetzt mal einen Server plattgehauen hat oder gleich mal ein paar hundert davon, dann fehlt erstmal irgendwas. Und die Techniken, mit denen das Netz diesen Defekt ausgleicht, die sind eigentlich so ähnlich, wie unser Gehirn das auch macht. Es werden die Routing-Tabellen geändert. Das heißt, oder sagen wir mal, sie ändern sich eigentlich von selbst, weil sie diesen Ausfall bemerken. Und es wird einfach ein anderer Weg gewählt, sodass man auch eine Fähigkeit, die durch eine Lesion verloren gegangen ist, doch wieder erlernen kann unter Umständen. Und genauso passiert es auch mit dem Netz. Und das ist eigentlich, ich denke mal, dass da oder jetzt für mich, ich denke jetzt im Moment, das ist noch nicht zu Ende gedacht, aber ich denke im Moment darüber nach, wie, wie dieses sozusagen, die Frage ist ja eigentlich, wie kommt denn das Ich sein und das Bewusstsein ins Gehirn? Und diese Frage kann man, diese Frage stelle ich jetzt einfach mal rein hypothetisch ans Netz.
Altpunk Origins, das ist eine News Group, wo derartige Diskussionen laufen. Und da habe ich schon einen ganz interessanten Stoff gefunden.
Was Sie interessieren sich für Ich-Findungen? Gar kein Problem. Mir ist übrigens wieder eingefallen, der Mensch ist ja ein Wunder, worüber ich vorhin reden wollte. Nämlich als ich mich mal mit Datenbanken beschäftigt habe, habe ich versucht zu begreifen, wie das funktioniert, wie so eine Datenbank Daten eben strukturiert und organisiert. Und dann gibt es irgendwie noch mal so ein bisschen eine kompliziertere Version. Relationale Datenbanken mit etwas komplexeren Verbindungen, die dann so aufeinander reagieren und so weiter. Okay, und dann kann ich so den Reflex auf mich selber machen und sagen, okay, bin ich, also diese Computermetapher übernehmen, bin ich auch eine Datenbank? Funktioniert das Gehirn als Speicher? Und rufe ich einfach Daten ab, wenn ich versuche mich zu erinnern? Und das ist für mich am Computer immer wieder interessant und da ist der Computer dann so ein Spiegel. Da sehe ich ein relativ komplexes Modell für Computerverhältnisse. Von etwas, wo auch ein kleiner Teil davon in meinem Bewusstsein stattfindet, das heißt dann eben erinnern. Und dann habe ich dran gedacht, also was jeder von uns kennt, ein Buchtitel fällt mir nicht gleich ein, liegt mir irgendwie auf der Zunge. Und vier Stunden später fällt er mir plötzlich ein. Und ich meinte, mich vorher zu erinnern zu haben, es ist ein Titel gewesen, das Buch muss irgendwie mit F angefangen haben. Und als es mir dann eingefallen ist, dann habe ich gesehen, Quatsch fängt mit W an, vom W verweht oder mit V. Und ich konnte mich aber erinnern, es ist immer irgendwie eher links oben im Bücherregal gestanden, es hatte irgendwie ein Fettfleck am Umschlag. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, wie es riecht, weil es ein altes Buch war oder so. Das heißt, da ist irgendwie, in diesen vier Stunden kann ich mich dann fragen, was ist da passiert? Da ist, wenn man jetzt technisch sprechen würde, ein Task gelaufen. Das heißt, ich habe irgendwas in mein Unterbewusstsein abgesenkt, das extrem hohe Arbeitsgeschwindigkeiten hat oder sozusagen mit großen Komplexitäten umgehen kann und es wühlt da irgendwie in meinen Erinnerungsbeständen auf eine Art und Weise, die ich nicht ganz nachvollziehen kann, von der ich aber überzeugt bin, dass sie in Teilen nichts mit dem zu tun hat, mit der Art und Weise, wie ein Computer sucht, weil das sehr mechanisch ist, was der Computer macht. Und ich bin ein Organismus. Das heißt, ich komme dann an so einen Punkt, wo ich im Krone genommen bin, ist der Computer für mich ein sehr interessanter Anlass, sehr differenziert über mich selber nachzudenken, zum Teil zu dem Schluss zu kommen, der Mensch ist fundamental anders als der Computer. Deswegen hatte ich vorhin, wo ich mich durch diese wunderschöne Musik etwas verlaufen hatte, war ich auf den Urmacher gekommen. Weil die Urmacher-Kunst ist der Höhepunkt in der Mechanik gewesen. Und dieses mechanische Denken der Mensch als Automat, oder alle Lebewesen als Automat und das Universum als großes Urwerk und Gott als der große Urmacher, das war sozusagen die Vollendung der Mechanik in der Philosophie, in der Weltanschauung, in der Religion. Und dieses mechanistische Weltbild ist im Grunde genommen was, was uns jetzt im 20. Jahrhundert so langsam gegen die Hutchnur gegangen ist, um das mal so ein bisschen salopp zu sagen. Das heißt, wir haben viele kluge Menschen und noch Auswegen gesucht aus diesen mechanistischen Weltbildern, ist dann asiatische Weltanschauungen, sind in Anspruch genommen worden. Es ist der Begriff der Ganzheitlichkeit, so holistische Weltbilder und so weiter in Betracht gezogen worden. Und ich glaube, es gibt heutzutage, wenn man jetzt über Visionen und über Zukunft redet, eine Gefahr, nämlich, dass man, wenn man zum Beispiel naturwissenschaftliche Texte heutzutage liest und sieht, dass diese Computermetapher, also überall wird in der Biologie zum Beispiel verschaltet, da wird irgendwie diese ganze Sprache aus der Computertechnik eigentlich zum Beispiel fließt in die Biologie ein. Also das soll dann so eine Anmutung von wieder wissenschaftlicher Objektivität geben, von technischer Präzision und Genauigkeit. Und ich fürchte aber, in vielen Teilen ist es so, dass diese alte mechanistische, unorganische Sprache und Denkweise einfach durch die Computermetapher sozusagen 1 zu 1 ausgetauscht und ersetzt wird, dass es überhaupt keinen Fortschritt im Denken gibt, dass sozusagen das Denken überhaupt nicht organischer, ganzheitlicher oder dass diese Versuche jetzt sozusagen aus dieser hölzernen oder stehlernen aus dieser Mechanistik irgendwie rauszukommen, dass da einfach eine Gefahr drin liegt, dass man da irgendwie sehr vorsichtig sein muss. Deswegen finde ich es auch immer wieder interessant, da ist ein Computer für mich, aber das ist halt eine Frage der Person. Das ist nicht jedermanns Sache, sich vor den Computer zu setzen und sich so inspirieren zu lassen, indem ich mich eben ins Netz stürze und so wie Vic irgendwie drüber nachdenke, das ist jetzt irgendwie ein großes Nervensystem für die ganze Welt oder ich beschäftige mich mit einer Datenbank und überlege, wie funktioniert eigentlich Erinnern oder was passiert in mir und mich nicht einfach so ohne Zweifel irgendwie auf diese Metaphorik einlass, sondern sage ich mach das mit dem Fragezeichen und vielleicht komme ich auf was Neues oder vielleicht habe ich Zweifel und das war bei mir auch so, wo ich sagte ich bin einfach hundertprozentig sicher es gibt eine Menge Dinge, die kein Computer jemals machen können wird, die ich als Mensch machen kann.
Das war eine höchst inspirierende Ausgabe vom Chaos Radio, wie ich finde, die in anderthalb Minuten zu Ende geht. Dann geht es weiter mit dem Night Flight hier mit Martin Petersdorf. Eine Frage mit ganz kurzen Antworten zum Schluss an die Veteranen, an die Rentner hier vom Chaos Computer Club, an Vau, an Vic, an Andi und an Peter Glaser. Ich wüsste gern von euch, wenn ihr zurückblickt auf eure Zeit, mit dieser Tastatur vor euch, mit der Maus oder auch nicht Maus, mit der Tastatur hauptsächlich spontan, was ist die Buchstabenkombination oder das Wort, was ihr in dieser ganzen Zeit am häufigsten eingegeben habt? Immer wiederkehrend. Also zum Beispiel sowas wie www, was man ja dauernd eintippt oder so. Aber jetzt mal auf diese Vergangenheit, die ja lange vor Swept reicht bei euch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ob es jetzt nun Telnet oder FTP ist oder so.
Zwei Worte, Test und Gaga.
Also für mich gab es eigentlich, ich habe eigentlich gar keine Worte eingegeben, sondern da müsstest du dann nach dem häufigsten Bildmuster fragen.
Ich bin Netzpublicist und von daher, weil ich in Deutsch schreibe, ist es das Wort die.
Naja, also ich entsinne mich noch an meinen ersten Homecomputer, ein Trash 80, der WF-CLS.
Das war so ein Chaosradio. Ich hoffe ihr hattet Spaß, ob ihr uns mit dem Radio gehört habt oder über Real Audio zum ersten Mal ganz live direkt, was mich sehr freut. Und ansonsten könnt ihr diese Audiofiles von den Sendungen später noch im Archiv abrufen. Das alles werdet ihr finden, wenn ihr auf www.fritz.de geht oder auf www.ccc.de, findet ihr alles was ihr braucht. Ansonsten Mail an uns, an fast alle, die hier in meinen Sendungen beteiligt sind, unter chaos.orb.de. Man kann aber auch Postkarten schreiben, die Fritz-Adresse ist auch nicht so schwer. Das war's, tschüss. Ihr müsst ja da noch so winken und Ciao, Hörer!